est ce que tu viens pour les vacances
non je n'ai pas changé d'agent
je serai je pense avoir sa bande à roy
auront des bouts de nos valeurs et
terrain est ce que tu viens pour l'avoir
à caen ce dont je n'ai pas changé à toi
l'adresse
je serai je pense à quoi auront 10 206
de chez moi pour naviguer
c'est rien et valença
[Musique]
ce
qui se passe à tous
[Musique]
à lui de l'homme en noir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en bas émission qui parle avec
nous ce soir
patrick bruel
albert dupontel
théo
action
mais quand on descend
astrid veillon
alors
[Musique]
attention les débats
le sénat
[Musique]
non
alors c'est de pire en pire y en a que
deux ce soir là ses terres il y avait
trois la semaine dernière ça a tout jeté
mais celle là celle là sont pas mal et
voir j'aime bien le j'aime bien les jeux
de mots de celle là assez bien laurent
et arnie
l'a13 original
ouais non la une praia sur deux années
les gens n'ont plus d'inspiration mais
jenson merde les gens sont j'ai pas les
gens sont dans la rue les gens me c'est
quoi ces dix heures de cpe l'a
pas entendu parler de cette fois je sais
j'ai vu à la télé oui
vous savez ce que c'est vous qui
et pour
qui et quand
j'allais être content de ce que villepin
vient de le retirer on a appris ce soir
poisson d'avril
avant de recevoir mon premier invité je
voudrais qu'on regarde ensemble et
milliard moment de la semaine précédente
ça sert tout le monde en a parlé je fais
bien et s'est présenté non ce week-end
c'est étonnant mais c'est préparé par
jean non toi tu peux pas bien voilà et
s'est préparé par josé navarre un
magnéto serge
gérard darmon la pure bull je t'ai vu
hier - ah ouais à la soupe populaire
bompard kuder
j'ai fait semblant de temps de
reconnaître c'était assez touchants ils
venaient prendre ces assauts puis l'été
il avait froid il était si jeune hacker
gérard darmon vous trouvez pas oui et
puis qu'est ce qu'ils aiment la soupe
dans votre mère a eu 11 enfants d'abord
parce qu'ils étaient très religieuse été
témoins de jéhovah tous très féconde oui
plus fécondes que religieux s'étaient
vérifiées
c'est pas faux bien sûr tout ce que je
dis n est pas faux ça dépend ça aussi
c'est pas faux
est ce que j'avais la rage de vivre
non
et pourquoi non pourquoi parce que j'ai
la rage de survivre mais pas la rage de
vivre voilà guillaume pelletier bonsoir
êtes secrétaire général du mpf le
mouvement pour la france conseiller
principal collaborateur de son président
philippe de villiers
bien alors dit que les bears bonsoir
conçoit dick rivers je le dis à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est-à-dire la [__] des
rivières oui bah oui dis que c'est la
[__] rivers c'est une sorte de popol
voilà
vous avez déclaré dans france soir en
2005 pour les uns je suis culte pour les
autres je suis branché oui il ya un
autre pierre que tu as oublié
alors pourtant quand même c'est pas si
simple parce que vous dites drucker ça
se passe pas bien à quoi drucker ils
vous ignorent ça se passe pas bien et
michel oui c'est un faux gentil m'invite
jamais on est pourquoi je vous invite
pas je sais pas
serge qui est dit il est trop broncher
pauvre du caire
dans ce nouvel album ya des chansons de
niro comme celle-là des chansons de
mickey 3d de benjamin biolay francis
cabrel est ce qui vous a pris on a fait
des cpe jeunes commenté
vite ça ressemble en rien à ce que j'ai
fait jusqu'à maintenant non parce que je
fais mon vrai métier qui tamise un peu
marre c'est
lennon que j'ai très bien connu dit
exactement la même chose j'en ai la
nausée connu genève a bien sûr je copain
avec paul mccartney j'ai connu jimi
hendrix quand il était guitariste
moi quand j'ai mangé mon premier
hamburger en 1965 à new york avec
marilyn avec mary j
en 2001 dans l'événement du jeudi vous
aviez de tester le viagra et vous aviez
dit que vous n'avez pas besoin non moi
j'avais raconté il avait fait un test
avec des tas de gens il y avait il y
avait une nagui à mon bas on va tout le
monde comme ça evènement uc et kbc la
jante est endormi ah oui si vous avez
fait de rassurer par sabine
est ce que vous avez un type d'homme
particulier
oui super mario
vous savez ce qu'il faut faire pour
retenir un homme
je crois que j'ai pas encore entré le
bon pour le moment
j'ai pas envie de retenir
il faut qu'ils viennent me trouver
oh là là
j'ai dit que
tu donnes tu sais que c'est vrai moi car
j'étais petit dit que c'était le nom de
tous les chiens d'arrêt
carte récréation vous avez le droit de
faire absolument tout ce que vous voulez
sur ce plateau pendant cinq minutes
vous imaginez que je vais sauter sur ma
voisine de droite moi j'allais
imaginaire et pas du tout de gauche 1-2
oui pourquoi non non non 6
et puis mireille dumas c'est juste parce
que je la connais pas non plus j'ai
jamais vu mais c'est vrai quand je
regarde la télé 'les femmes physiquement
je sais pas enfin tu la quittes matière
mans je la kiffe ouais ouais ouais je
sais physique que ça super mirettes
ouais alternant des trucs ça s'explique
pas tu vois et lara croft tu la trouves
comment par rapport à mireille dumas je
veux dire
ouais super moche enfin un gros taux
mirail est trop fort
celui ou celle qui va trouver ça sera la
star de la télé ça il ya deux semaines
et après tu as envoyé le générique fin
je suis même pas eu à la star la star de
quoi faire du générique la star des
loges l'ambassade et rentre chez toi
pour baltringue
j'ai même pas envie de prouver que tu as
tellement
derrière je rentre tous les maires dont
quinze jours que tu m'as pas toucher de
qualité
celle ci est pas les gosses 1
j'accueille patrick bruel
il
ouais
je m'attendais pas
[Musique]
oh
autre chose
patrick bruel déjà numéro comme album
mesdames messieurs
mais avant de parler du nouvel album de
patrick bruel et à saint dizier
non
mais
vos dents
[Applaudissements]
je trouve pas leurs fins anneaux
soit
[Musique]
oh
tous les maux j'aime bien
sont dérisoires
qui a le droit
il y a
qui
ça
parent
enfant
qui croit
ce que je disais
[Musique]
j'te mentirais
si je te disais au fond des yeux
lamont tom a coulé
cette fille ne fait que passer
et
[Musique]
elle me trouvais
alors
doucet
voilà
alors la dernière chanson qu'on a
entendu patrick est extraite de entre
deux votre précédent album qui s'est
vendu à deux millions huit cent mille
exemplaires
on nous avait dit tu vas te plante était
bardot avec les chansons de pépé au
début personne n'y croyait ni la famille
ni les amis ni la maison de disques non
c'est sûr ce n'était pas trop ça fait
pas l'unanimité non 1 mais bon c'est
ce qui m'a beaucoup étonné c'est take on
me parlait de risque ouais on me disait
mais tu prends un risque énorme je vais
pas bien où est elle risque le seul
risque c'est éventuellement que les gens
énorme entre 50000 voilà ils n'en
veulent pas et aux moins jeunes a été
fait très très je savais je m'étais fait
plaisir ce qui était marrant c'est que
deux millions huit cent mille albums
plus tard
c'était devenu une bonne idée ouais
ouais c'est ça les gens ont dit c'est
une très grande idée marque était alors
que début personne n'y croyait quoi bon
enfant tout cas ça a marché alors
aujourd'hui vous revenez avec un album
de chansons inédites
le premier depuis six ans qui s'appelle
des souvenirs devant alors c'est un
disque assez assez simple assez sobre
sans voix cassée sans guitares saturées
assez assez classique et c'est un disque
autobiographique où vous essayez de
trouver finalement ce qu'il ya dans
votre intimité d'universel c'est est-ce
que ce qui fait partie de mon intimité
et puis le regarder je peux avoir sur
les choses à at il ou pas un caractère
universel ça la réponse ne pouvait
donner que par le public visiblement
depuis une semaine c'est le cas donc ça
va bien ça marche énorme je suis content
très content très content et très fier
parce que ces indices que j'aime au delà
de tout
alors ça faisait longtemps que vous
tourniez autour du truc vous aviez des
musiques prête depuis deux ans
vous écoutiez ça avec un bloc à la main
chez vous vous n'arriviez pas vraiment
vous y mettre oui j'avais plusieurs
plusieurs raisons peut-être là la plus
apparente c'était que je venais de me
balader pendant quatre ans avec des avec
des chefs-d'oeuvre des années 30 et que
me remettre à écrire il est toujours la
sensation
le spectre de charles trenet derrière
moi en train de me dire tu es gentil
laisse tomber ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'un jour un jour du mois d'août
dernier votre femme amanda vous dites
j'ai pris une telle musique j'ai
commencé à écrire un texte termine là si
si ça t'intéresse quoi exactement
elle manie surtout ça commence à bien
faire
la force d'écouter les chansons en
boucle et très dire ouais ça va être un
très très grand 10 15 jours et j'avais
pas un mot elle a pris une musique elle
est avec le texte dit moi j'ai fait ça
si ça te plaît tu l'a terminée que cet
album commence et ça a été un vrai
déclencheur là parce que le texte était
sublime ça s'appelle la chanson
s'appelle je fais semblant sa première
chanson du disque qui dit beaucoup de
choses de mon parcours de ma vie a dit
je joue à croire que je mérite tout ça
c'est à dire c'est un peu sur l'autre
côté un peu sûr de vous un peu frimeur
quoi tu es sur mon côté non c'était
disons que c'est l'as masnières mode
donné le change ouais de vouloir
toujours rassurés et de vouloir toujours
dire que tout va bien ce soit à ma mère
à mes proches à mon entourage et puis
surtout à moi-même c'est une manière
mais qu'elle est qu'elle est décelée 7 7
7 cette faille de ma personnalité
c'était assez assez troublant ça m'a
motivé si on perd et epci en même temps
il est toujours même fait donc c'est
peut-être pour cela et c'est certain
mais est-ce qu'il faut être une fille de
psy est une femme mariée pour trouver ça
chez vous il fallait quelqu'un
d'intelligent et dément ouais en tout
cas
et mais je pense que le parcours qui
avait fait
la traversée en éducation joujou
énormément oui pareil que nous a raconté
salies cycle quand elle était petite
elle était planquée dans un placard dans
le bureau de son père elle assistait à
l'assistance à ces canalisations quand
même dingue ce qui était dingue c'est
surtout qu'il qui sont pris avec qui la
laisse la wii alors une chanson qui
s'appelle je m'attendais pas à toi qui
te sujet de damman da donc mes mails à
quoi cet amendement pour quelques les
autres n'ont pas annoncé heureusement à
la cua très beaucoup de qualités
beaucoup de folie d'accord mais aux
qualités beaucoup de qualités humaines
elle est au delà de ça
je crois qu'il ya pas d'histoire qui
tiennent sans admiration ouais j'ai une
profonde admiration pour la femme qu'à
la fondation pour l'auteur qu'elle est
là oui ça marche très bien sa pièce la
pièce en train de faire le vieux juif
blonde
trio c'est pas un homme triomphe c'est
c'est une grosse surprise pour tout le
monde et
ccc ce formidable
c'est ce qui se passe non je vois ma
fille l'a bien mais bien mon graphique
au début vous le laissez un peu
[Musique]
non
non je ne connais pas très beau début
pour l'été se chauffer donc on est en
droit de se demander ce qu avait amanda
j'écoute les autres n'ont pas bon alors
elle a aimé voilà c'est ce que moi je
lui ai trouvé ouais sûrement mais elle
vous tient tête aux sinon c'est ça un
peu d'en haut et bien sûr elle s'écrase
pas je suis sûr c'est pas le genre de
concert ça c'est crade et non mais c'est
pas ce genre à avoir beaucoup de
relations et d'affection pour les champs
qui s'écrasa vincent d'accord ouais mais
tellement heureux maintenant dans la vie
qu'à une chanson qui s'appelle peine de
mélancolie donc vous n'avez pas
d'inspiration mais il faut être triste
en général pour écrire des très bonnes
chansons alors c'est dur d'écrire quand
on est heureux effectivement on vous dit
à part charles trenet bah c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt en général écrit des
chansons sur des histoires d'amour qui
se casse la gueule ouais là n'ont donc
je me suis mis dans la peau du mec qui
arrive pas à trouver une source
d'inspiration et qui fait tout pour ça
et qui va s'enfermer dans des salles
obscures un des films qui font pleurer
qui enfin tout un tas de choses dites
dans l'ascension c'est une grande source
d'inspiration le manque d'inspiration en
ce moment non mais les irrigants soucy
attaque en règle
j'ai voulu pimenter la course c'est pas
mal mais pas une vanne mais c'est ce que
tu m'intéresses alors au moment des
émeutes dans les banlieues à l'automne
vous aviez envie d'écrire une chanson là
dessus quoi et vous vous trouviez pas où
vous aviez du mal dites vous à éviter la
démagogie la langue de bois et amanda
toujours elle vous a suggéré de
rechercher dans le passé on a beaucoup
discuté et on est arrivé à la conclusion
que eux
à priori que une révolte une révolution
ressemble beaucoup à une autre révolte
une autre évolution donc on a réfléchi
un peu ce qu'ils s'étaient qui avait pu
se passer qui avait plu et crée on est
vite arrivé sur la commune la commune je
suis vite arriver à victor hugo et quand
on a quelqu'un qui a fait hypokhâgne et
khâgne à côté de soi c'est sûr qu'elle a
tout comme elle a tout lu est là mais
elle a lu les plaidoyers un de victor
hugo que je connaissais pas à dompter
m'a dit voilà regarde ça j'ai regardé
les plaidoyers et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est l'actualité
édifiant de ce texte qui est écrit donc
à 135 ans et dans lequel il y as au
milieu du texte par exemple une phrase
qui dit il fallait leur donner leur part
de la cité et votre aveuglement produits
leur cécité un partir de cette phrase la
plus la phrase d'hésitation dans
laquelle est plongée victor hugo à cette
époque la cantine quand il s'attaque à
ce sujet m'a donné une forme de
légitimité et l envie de 2 qu'il
m'accompagne pour aujourd'hui dire
quelque chose pour faire et puis pour
faire valoir le grand visionnaire qu'il
était alors voilà bien une chanson sur
votre mère ce qu'elle raconte moi cette
vie avant de m'avoir mon père colomb
béchar nous habituer à colomb béchar ils
ont ils ont enseigné ensemble à colomb
béchar et c'était avant que j'arrive
puis une chanson sur votre fils aussi ma
maison de papier tu poses tes yeux sur
moi je deviens pas pas si jolie donc oui
oui c'est très touchant parce qu il la
chante
[Musique]
attendez
tout le monde
et
[Musique]
oh
voilà patrick bruel extrait de son
dernier album des seniors les amateurs
de patois la
patrie oui vous aimez les défis et des
filles oui vous les défis ou bien les
dix huit heures qu'est ce qu'il va dire
interdit aux obsèques d'anne la plus
dure
un enfer à la tension
est la plus dure et pourquoi j'ai la
plus dure mois si vous êtes le meilleur
pourquoi
alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter de
pire en ce moment
que le réveil sonne et qu'on me dise que
que tout ça n'était qu'un rêve ouais
quels défauts aimeriez vous avoir
la rancune
ça m'arrive est un peu rancunier mais
cette menace avait des accords non
savoir assez vite quel est le calendrier
ne riez pas avoir
de talent je vais
donner des ordres ouais
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir
cali shantz interview
je peux appeler ma femme
la qualit cassé c'est quoi la question
par la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir
j'ai parfois un peu trop consensuelle
ouais en quoi aimeriez-vous être
beaucoup plus mauvais
beaucoup plus mauvais mais qui pense
qu'il est bon en tout
je ne sais pas je sais pas on est
l'interview peut-être peut-être
pas une puissance qui ne voudriez vous
pas avoir comme femme à aïn à un pack
ouais j'ai bien jeu
ça va vous c'est vrai vous je vous
engage directement prochaine tournée
maintenant qui j'aimerais pas avoir
comme fan on va il ya plein de gens qui
me vient à l'idée tiens par exemple
ghana
par exemple
si par hasard s'il y en a un qui me vint
qui me vient à l'esprit pas le borgne
non mais justement imagine imagine
jean-marie en train de chanter i habib
sy a line dance
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour qu'elle vous séduisent
eux tous maintenant pour tous j'ai
toujours peur parce que je re classe je
reviens une phrase que j'avais dit un
jour comme ça on m'a dit qu'avec lé
dossier pour la femme idéale j celle
dont j'aimerais tous les défauts
d'accord oui voilà c'est ça celles dont
les défauts me paraissent charmant et
voilà jusqu'au jour où ici le son -
alors là c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait envie
d'être trompé par une femme ballon bon
ça lui viennent à l'esprit
ça lui viennent à l'esprit au moment où
je sais pas comment la quitter voilà
avec un bonne réponse quand avez vous
déjà été heureux d'être quitté par bah
quand j'étais plus amoureux comme quand
même tous les hommes un peu lâche j'ai
laissé pourrir
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir
[__] ouais bravo
quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus c'est ce qui est arrivé il ya
pas longtemps dans un aéroport c'est
j'adore vos chansons mais c'est jacques
brel ouais
très bien sauté du commun le mec là
j'aime ça aussi avec francis cabrel
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que vos
enfants rate
beaucoup de choses pour que
pour qu'ils aient la la la notion de
l'échec pour pouvoir apprécier mieux le
l'éventuel succès enfin je sais pas si
c'est très clair ce que je dis ouais
j'aurais pu durer troisième guerre
mondiale
ah ouais
ouais la troisième guerre mondiale
c'est vrai aussi passé vous
qui aimez vous détestez
je vais vous détestez
le rock m16 ici s'il est violent mais
les dents les gars avec qui je joue au
poker mais voilà d'accord ça c'est les
seuls moments où on peut aimer détester
quelqu'un ouais parce que dans la
relation on est obligé de détester
quelqu'un qui est en face de vous quand
on veut quand on veut gagner
par qui aimeriez-vous et détesté détesté
par une femme parce qu'il paraît que
c'est un signe ah ouais vous dire sans
raison quelqu'un qui déteste comme ça
sans raison oui ça peut être un signe de
grande excitation
d'autant qu'elle est qu'elle est la
récompense que vous avez reçue qui ne
vous honore pas
trop [__] c'est super dur
qu'elle allait récompense que j'ai reçu
deux morts pas avait il ya trois
négation de la formation d'élite et il
va voir faut avoir fait huit ans de 2,2
le psychanalyste est d'abord
tapé la francisque non il ya une
récompense qui nous honore pas oui les
cris des femmes qui ont simulé ah bravo
regardons ça m'étonnerait ceci étant ça
méchamment et qu on simule avait bien
sont là ce soir
quelle est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait
meilleur mauvaises critiques meilleur
mauvaise critique tu vas marcel lattois
meilleur mauvaises critiques
c'est un chanteur populaire ah ouais
ouais peut-être est la pire bonnes
critiques
la pire bonnes critiques c'est celle que
les gens vous font dans une loge quand
ils viennent vous voir au théâtre et qui
vous disent tu été formidable mais c'est
un rôle en or ah oui d'accord et c'est
terry parce que le rôle en dehors c'est
qu'on l'a bien fait et tu peux rien
répond tu fais ces abrutis
quel est votre plus belle erreur
de croire que tout est possible et votre
pire victoire
c'est d'avoir
de n'avoir pas chanter dans l'élite
front national de penser aujourd'hui que
j'ai eu raison
[Musique]
jacques outin un mandat non c'est un
copain
[Musique]
bonjour il est chaud
carte haute yes vous devez désigner la
plus jolie fille du public
c'est demain
de tarot à partir du 17 octobre et
ensuite en tournée
sa grand mère
j'accueille claude ferran et albert
dupontel
bonsoir bonsoir claude bonsoir albert
pons par monsieur andrew alberts on vous
quittant pianiste virtuose dans fauteuil
d'orchestre de danièle thompson et on
vous retrouve en sdf déjanté dans votre
nouveau film qui s'appelle enfermés
dehors
alors le pitch c'est un sdf qui trouve
un uniforme de flic et il va s'en servir
pour aider une femme interprétée par
claude a retrouvé sa petite fille et se
casse sociale devient en fait sa raison
d'exister il décide de jouer les
justiciers voilà vous dit le pitch m'est
venue un soir où je songe à me venger du
monde extérieur c'est à dire un peu tous
les soirs il dit ensuite j'ai cherché
comment raconter et l'aspect cartoon
sociale m'a paru de bon aloi c'est vrai
que c'est un cartoon sociale voilà voilà
c'est la meilleure définition du film
qu'on puisse ainsi vous le dites moi je
pense que c'est ça cartoon en gros et
sociale en petit c'est vrai qu'on pense
aux polices man de chaplin mais la
réalisation est traitée que savent rire
oui john jones aussi ouais ouais je la
bd films mais quoi mais voilà je fais du
monde d'accord
non c'est pas qu'on était sur écoute
alors c'est un film assez c'est
burlesque qui fait ma règle des choses
désespérées comme tout ce qui est
burlesque quoi désespérer des algériens
on prend le terreau social qui existe et
qui on part de ça je ne pourront pas
d'un constat campana porter une
révélation aux gens si c'est une
révélation qui a des airs dans la rue
des banquiers véreux le 20 heures est
une tragédie
par contre l'idée c'était d'avoir un
procès des grands guigne cartoon est
strictement pour raconter tout ça mais
monsieur qui ai fait ça très bien il ya
cent ans qui s'appelait chaplin ouais
donc c'est une revisite très humble et
très personnelle des gourbis
chaplinesque voilà alors vous dites ce
film est né d'une attitude inconsciente
qui consiste à regarder les travers du
monde avec un nez rouge oui c'est vous
quoi ben voilà
oui mais c'est plus drôle que bernie
quoi certains seulement bernie tu es
drôle aussi mais simplement que la y
avait un côté il ya un côté plus bénins
dans ce personnage là parce que dès le
départ ses ambitions sont plus triviale
il veut boire manger et être aimé le
regard ni vu ça frustre itude vouloir un
nom était déjà quelque chose de très
j'avais pas vu quoi voilà donc ces
nouvelles dans le mur voilà mais c'est
là la fin positif de ce film est aussi
honnête que la fin négative des derniers
n'étaient qu il s arrêtait une faute de
goût de faire ce film mal se terminer
voilà on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
j'ai regardé tous les deux la caméra
vous allez dire magnéto serge cals rouge
claude voilà hockey magnéto toi aussi
apprendre à manier tout en mettant un
deux trois mais on est tous super gt
mais
si par exemple tu es de la police un tu
fais un coût mais la police il ya une
dame qui te demande de l'aider dans la
rue 17 gagne par exemple elle te dis
qu'on lui a plu son bébé 6,6 à
m'expliquer je me la sucer le parc a
fait ça aime aussi des lacs la gueule
c'est des gens il faut les décapiter
vivant et lapidé à coups de hache et
j'en fais du pâte et du papier
[Musique]
j'ai toujours été attiré par les poules
c'est le nouveau film d'albert
dakar
alors que l'actrice fétiche de déduire
dentelle vous êtes dans tous ses films
dont bernie dans le dans le créateur
dans enfermés dehors et vous avez dit en
parlant de claude je préfère les grandes
actrices rare aux mauvaises très
fréquentes
ça j'étais sûr c'était journaux détails
qu'elle et lui plaire
vous êtes un petit peu langue de chat
foule je demande est acquis qu'il
pensait
à kehl aux personnes c'est vrai que je
trouvais avec l'autre c'est un pur sang
qui piaffent et j'aime bien utiliser les
fausses sur le mode d'emploi donc voilà
non mais c'est des buttes à tout ça
c'est pas sérieux thierry le film n'est
pas sérieux je ne suis pas sérieux rien
n'est sérieux voilà vous aimez beaucoup
vous dites son animalité sa tendresse en
même temps ouais là peut-être qu'elle
peut l'expliquer mais pour moi ça reste
en page et animale
animal peut-être dans le sens où je suis
plutôt instinctive que cérébral en tout
cas pour le jeu et
et d'ailleurs dans la vie aussi sujets
phares gfa j'ai soif de swaps et voilà
pourtant au départ il a essayé pour une
actrice espagnole à votre place quand
même elle est morte oui c'est vrai oui
j'ai fait un contrat contre elle faut
pas déconner
ça s'est pas fait avec l'actrice
espagnole dont les morts voilà donc il a
il a ramé pour vous pour vous re
conquérir aux aidants à chier
elle est élégante quand elle joue vous
l'avez fait attendre longtemps avant de
dire oui j'ai pris mon temps j'ai fait
le tour du périgord
non non non non ça c'est pas fait comme
ça tout à fait donc il ya eu cette
actrice espagnole parce qu'il voulait en
fait enfin ils vous diraient mieux que
moi ils voulaient que ce qu'elle soit
étrangère pour accuser encore le fait
qu'elle soit perdue par rapport à
l'administration française et pour
récupérer son bébé et puis et puis donc
elle était plus jeune aussi pour encore
le côté plus vulnérables et donc il est
resté encore en pensée sur sept jeunes
de jeunes personnes dans l'idée est
donc petit à petit sous la menace la
torture
il a fini par réaliser qu'en fait il
avait en face de lui le cas de beaucoup
mieux
au départ c'est une coproduction franco
espagnole en fait mieux alors au départ
même avant ça c'était un projet
américain avait tenté l'expérience
américaine vous avez pensé à robin
williams et jake nicholls appels du pied
du cinéma indépendant américain et en
être vaniteux j répondu voilà avoir un
sursaut de lucidité de revenir en france
mais j'ai perdu un petit peu tanger que
j'ai croisé des personnes très
intéressantes et très enthousiaste vous
dites ils sont marrants comme celle soir
mais le lendemain on est en face de
leurs agents et c'est déjà beaucoup
soufflé branimir ferme jamais je n'irai
donc c'est facile de manger avec eux de
s'amuser et c'est authentique mais dès
qu'on commence à travailler c'est
compliqué et puis surtout je peux avoir
ou pas je pouvais pas voir le contrôle
de mon travail ça me gênait beaucoup
quoi je suis revenu en france
précipitamment et j'ai reconstitué une
petite équipe de vernis vert or claude
voilà a été beaucoup plus sage mais vous
avez passé quand même temps la barre je
fais des allers retours pendant 18 mois
a indiqué m
vous n'êtes pas acharné hollywood quoi
non non non non faut pas alors le film
s'est monté en france n'est pas évident
d'arriver à le monter parce que c'est
vrai que le créateur savait pas été un
énorme succès non mais c'est ça c'est
surtout une question de le principal
investisseur du cinéma enfance et la
télévision à la télévision est forcément
friands de ce genre de produits voilà
j'ai gagné j'ai même passé en clair ce
si bête que ça donc j'ai pas de
l'audimat à m j'ai un score au
box-office mais pas forcément le 10 mars
est ou non mais c'est logique aussi çà -
doit savoir c'est une partie du talent
c'est de savoir se vendre il faut c'est
quand il s'agit pas d'un film culte et
derrière thuram pour faire des films
c'est
enfin je ne me plains pas donc je
connais les règles du jeu on vous dit je
m'ennuie souvent au cinéma surtout avec
sept postes nouvelle vague qui n'en
finit plus de mourir c'est que souvent
le cinéma à l'étranger français doit
être considérée comme la nouvelle vague
quand il veut des films qui ne ressemble
pas la nouvelle vague ils sont surpris
dit c'est pas du cinéma je suis trop
dans la cuisine où pierre est parti
parce que karol arrivée serait capable
si
on a quelques experts sur le cake
quelques eu quelques expériences aux
états unis qui était curieuse ce qui est
des gens venaient sorte en disant c'est
pas du cinéma français donc on était un
peu embêté on est à la stricte
culturellement à la nouvelle vague a
fait des dégâts malgré tout pour les
petits gars comme nous voilà c'est tout
alors c'est fini le wegmans pour
toujours et ça fait 15 ans
qu'il a pas un truc quoi non non non je
mange ça ne manque pas voilà
vous avez fait en fait des courts
métrages avant de faire des sketchs les
sketches et juste une façon de faire
connaître finalement c'est une porte qui
s'est ouverte et je réussirai toujours
les gens comme sebastian marafa la
télévision parce que c'est ce qu'elle
s'amusait beaucoup mes copains à l'école
de théâtre où j'étais chez vitesse et
c'est vrai que c'était il ya 15 ans a
duré 18 mois je me suis jamais profité
d'une carrière là-dessus avec les sous
du spectacle à titre d'anecdote j'ai
produit mon premier commettra s'appelle
désirait que dans les bonus venu du
créateur et puis voilà ça s'appelle
avoir la suite dans les idées et se
succèdent temps combret quelque part non
pas du tout sincèrement ça me frustrait
puisque jamais la caméra tout ce travail
on a souvent parlé donc j'aime bien cet
outil qu'est la caméra chaud ça très
beau très souple ça me fascine à tort ou
à raison j'en sais rien ça me plaît
beaucoup la scène de frustré parce que
je n'étais que tout - seul sur scène tu
vois c'était frustrant comme expression
voilà donc c'est juste ça on ne veut pas
arrêter par roger arrêté puisqu'il y
avait une femme plus belle qui
m'attendait voilà c'est aussi bête que
ça
bien voilà enfermé dehors donc sorti le
5 avril alors le film le pitch comme je
le dis c'est un sdf qui enfile un
costume de flic alors offert une
interview si vous étiez fric
si vous étiez plus que ce serait pour
quelles raisons non pas par nécessité de
manger voilà je pense à un crs qui
s'énerve actuellement dans les manies
sait s'ils pouvaient faire notre boulot
je crois qu'il le ferait ouais bah oui
je pense et ce quasi fasoli nés en 68 il
a dit les vraies prolétaires ce sont les
crs sans aller jusqu'à cet engagement
politique je pense sincèrement c'est de
la casse il pouvait éviter de le faire
ils le feraient quoi simplement on les
manipule on leur fout sur la gueule et
les étudiants les flics ses trousses
assez consternant comme spectacle un
jeune un flic qui se bat avec un un
jeune en banlieue c'est un pauvre qui se
veulent qu'un pur et ça fait juste
quelqu'un qui manipule tout seul team
sur sa totalement désolant parce que la
personne qui avait ses voitures brûlées
à mettre dans la merde par contre la
personne qui ça profite fera monter les
cotisations d'assurance et sa voiture
sera jamais brûlé puisque les victoires
même quartier donc je trouve ça un peu
d'aisé vraiment anti sociales cdc parti
socialiste j'ai de la compassion j'ai de
la compassion pour ces gens et je
comprends les deux camps je suis navré
de voir le spectacle de la société
actuellement de séjour de droite et de
gauche qui se fout sur la gueule ça me
désole quoi il ya autre chose à [__]
dans ce pays comme dans du lait a priori
ils ont toutes les compétences requises
ce qui n'est pas le cas de laurent
nîmois de gurun il pourrait faire des
choses bien et on les voit sont violées
dans des débats puérils et ça je trouve
ça désolant franchement il ya beaucoup
de gens dans ce pays qui n'ont qu'une
envie en fait c'est que c'est trouver
des solutions parce qu'à des problèmes
mais la juvénilité la classe politique
est absolument navrant j'ai presque eu
le sentiment que la masse ce qu'on
appelle la masse silencieuse des masses
populaires a plus de maturité que les
gens qui nous dirigent j'en suis sûr
regarde moi je vote pas j'assume
complètement
les allées sont trop disciplinés à
chaque foyer vous pouvez dire daniel
maissant vous pouvez m'insulter faisait
le droit
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est si je votais je voterai blanc lé
vote blanc n'étant pas validé en france
du coup je me retrouve un peu embêté
c'est parce que je m'organise aucun
discours mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que si le vote blanc est un été validée
on pourrait de façon pacifique et
intelligent influencer sur démocratie je
rejette ce candidat là je range est il
est pas normal qu en 2002 on est le
choix entre le pire et le moins pire et
je veux dire c'est un grand pays ce pays
normalement c'est ce que j'entends dire
partout on a eu 30 % de votes blancs et
on aurait recommencé les élections et
c'est pas plus mal jusqu'à citer des
candidats qui plaisent aux gens le vote
blanc crée de la valeur que si le vote
est obligatoire pas forcément il ya des
tas de gens qui rêvent de voter blanc de
façon à changer la règle du jeu oui si
le vote est obligatoire le vote blanc
serait considéré beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup donc en commençant par donner
le vote blanc est en tout cas d'états
gens iront voter
aujourd'hui le vote blanc donne là une
voie à
savoir plus fort malheureusement si elle
si tu votes si tu avais je te dise il
était valide constitue seulement il
n'existe pas de votre vie actuellement
six ont décidé que 15 ou 20 % de votes
blancs étaient pouvait invalider
l'élection des tas de gens se mettra à
voter de façon à changer pacifiquement
la règle d'un jeu que personne ne
comprend actuellement c'est ce que je
dis actuellement gauthier doit
effectivement revient pas faire grand
chose donc voilà voilà autant qu'il
était clairement au moins quand on sait
pas pour qui voter on peut savoir contre
si vous étiez flic est ce que j'en
mettrais le plus bas depuis
n'en est pas des flics par contre les
fixes et un boulot difficile et qui n'a
pas forcément la considération des gens
autour de soi quoi il n'y a pas de bons
flics et de mauvais fixé peut avoir des
effets meute qui se contentent en main
mais comment il y ait des effets me tout
d'un coup il ya comme des mauvais
supporters tu les prends appareils sont
gentils sont autant de gages et revient
il ya quand même des gros cons comme un
peu comme partout
[Musique]
si vous étiez flics vous arrêteriez qui
en premier
moi même voilà pour éviter de faire
l'économie avec tout ce pouvoir et vous
laisseriez filet qui si vous étiez flic
moi-même pour pas ma liberté oui je sais
que vous soyez sûr qu'ici vous êtes chez
flic personnes les meubles feriez quoi
comme bavure des films bonne réponse
ne fait pas tout ce qui vous demande de
faire
voter blanc et vous je le trouve aussi
[__] c'est une catastrophe merci
mais
moi ça me ferait plaisir ça ça va mal
voilà bah j'ai je me semble plus jeune
je me sens fier le si je devais je
ressens vient d'être français mais voilà
si c'est bien l'esprit critique il faut
percer infiniment du fond du coeur voilà
tu expliques joueriez surtout avec quel
accessoire
le sifflet pour faire du bruit si vous
étiez si vous espériez plus les noirs ou
les arabes la connerie ce métier flics
vous seriez un peu excité chaque fois
vous passer des menottes à quelqu'un
si j'étais tout nu peut-être je sais pas
j'avais essayé
tuner thierry que j'utiliserai quelle
méthode pour faire parler les gens ne
votent blanc
métier c'est quel délit laisseriez-vous
impuni le le pétard pas déconner quand
même le pétard oui les pétards faut
qu'ils aient de nouveau maire d'aytré
vie paraît que c'est très dangereux un
coup sur deux il y avait un rapport
comme quoi c'était une drogue douce ya
deux ans puis maintenant c'est très
dangereux de deux ans nous dira j'ai moi
même je me faut arrêter c'est trop bien
construit mais jusqu'au prochain rapport
est meilleur que ce dernier si vous
expliquer ce que vous seriez amour et de
nicolas sarkozy je démissionnerai
vivant c'est l'envers tordu le sac à dos
et de toi car
hop
vous devez casser quelque chose sur ce
plateau c'est trop tentant une autre
vous devez convaincre villepin de
retirer le cpe [__]
regarde sa caméra le
dominique il y à d'autres genres dans ce
pays que l'état major de matignon pense
à nous
j'accueille charlotte valandrey
bonsoir ou charlotte
alors charlotte donc héroïne de rouge
baiser le film de véra belmont qui vous
a valu un prix d'interprétation au
festival de berlin fille du commissaire
cordier dans cordier juge et flic vous
vivez depuis 20 ans charlotte avec le
virus du sida et à l'heure de la
cinquième édition du sidaction merci
d'être avec nous pourrons pour en parler
je rappelle d'ailleurs à ce sujet là
qu'il faut composer le 110 alors et
tenir les promesses parce que dire je
vais donner c'est bien mais le faire
c'est mieux voilà et les numéros et
gratuit voilà alors ce que je voulais
dire simplement au sujet du sidaction
cdd des chiffres qu'on connaît pas bien
c'est que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui il
ya une personne qui meurt du sida toutes
les dix secondes
et une personne est contaminée par le
virus toutes les six secondes en france
il ya cent mille séropositifs et 5000
nouveaux séropositifs parents et à 40
millions de personnes séropositives et
est morte du sida à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui et en 2010 y en aura 100
millions
ce qui est terrible c'est qui encore 29%
des français qui pensent qu'il existe un
vaccin contre le sida ouais et 30 % qui
pensent qu'on ne meurt pas du sida ouais
n'y a pas de vaccin évidemment le seuil
pour vraiment le dire d'abord à dire il
n'y a pas de vaccin ça n'existe pas
vraiment voilà ils sont pas prêts de le
trouver de l'avoir trouvé
le seul remède c'est la trithérapie
aujourd'hui vous dites mais médicaments
mais médoc sont mes bienfaiteurs et mes
boules et miniatures
ouais c'est pas tout le temps drôle
ouais j'aime quand on les oublie faut
aller les chercher revenir pour faire le
tour de paris où espère accompagner allé
chercher un bon aloi un petit à 2 heures
d'écart quand même on va pas mais c'est
pas bien des who eh ouais d'ailleurs la
justesse ou
non mais oui
mais je supporte assez bien je crois que
je vais encore là dessus je trouve que
j'ai de la chance par ya pas tellement
d'effets secondaires quoi parce que des
fois il ya un prennent de répartition
des graisses allait quand même ça ouais
au bout de wayne bout de 8 ans 9 ans de
trithérapie
sa marque sa marque un peu quand même
plus la greffe en tout cas la cortisone
bon ça et non pas les yeux assez gentil
je vous ai vu dans le film de véra
belmont ya longtemps je
regarde annoncé à 23,85 à la fin quand
j'avais 20 ans et ya pas mal de potes
ont choisi
des vomissements aussi non moi j'en ai
j'en fais j'en ai pas beaucoup
donc fait pas tellement d'effets
secondaires en ce qui vous concerne à
part le changement physique j'avoue que
voilà oui
c'est pas pour autant que enfin c'est
important de dire que
c'est pas la majeure partie des cas quoi
il ya beaucoup de
k qui ont dès qu'ils en prennent d'abord
beaucoup
et qui ont des effets secondaires en
effet sont des maux de tête des
diarrhées des vomissements
des enfin tous pour tout ce qui est
agréable enfin bref donc elle ni vaccin
ni remède miracle mais dit le
préservatif n'est pas négociable non
voilà en 2006 ouais
alors ce n'est que c'est pas toujours
facile même vous vous raconter qu'à un
moment vous êtes tombée amoureuse d'un
électricien sur un film avec qui vous
faisait l'amour sans préservatif c'est à
dire qu' il ya des moments où c'est
extrêmement difficile quoi oui il ya des
moments où
on aime très fort quelqu'un et quand on
est aimé très fort c'est vrai qu'on fait
pas forcément toujours ce qu'il faut
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose que je
préconise bien sûr on pense que l'amour
est tellement fort que finalement ça on
sera pas malade quoi c'est un ouais
c'est un peu ça et puis jean la grande
trace et j'ai confiance parce qu'il veut
rien dire non c'est
non mais en plus quand on prend la
trithérapie enfin en ce qui me concerne
mon et le virus est en dessous du seuil
de détection donc c'est vrai que ça
voilà mais bon ce n'est pas du tout ce
que je vois comment ouais mais comment
peut-on être tombée amoureuse d'un
électricien
est ce que ça donne dans le cadre est
bien vrai cet opérateur aujourd'hui
l'autre fois vous avez fait l'amour sans
préservatif c'était pour faire votre
fille tara est là c'est extraordinaire
parce que finalement on on sait
maintenant que des femmes séropositives
qui sont sous trithérapie vraiment bien
suivre ouais
un pour cent de risque d'avoir un enfant
contaminé très bonne nouvelle ça bah oui
c'est vrai je joue bien alors ça se
passe comment votre vie aujourd'hui
charlotte
bien les des bons résultats ouais les
derniers s'en vont en tout cas ouais
ouais j'ai toujours eu du bien à dire
très bien parce que j'ai toujours peur
qu'après cela soit mal donc mais pas mal
du tout
vous dites c'est pas facile de dire à
son partenaire de mettre un préservatif
c'est plus facile de lui dire de mettre
un préservatif et que de lui dire qu'on
est séropositif
bah oui c'est vrai
c'est beaucoup plus facile alors vous
conseiller de faire des tests au moindre
doute vous vous l'avez fait mais même
sans avoir de doute ces mêmes faut même
pas attendre d'avoir un doute pour aller
faire un test faut le faire quoiqu'il
enfin quoiqu'il arrive dès qu'on y pense
il faut y aller parce que c'est hyper
important de savoir si on est
séropositif ou pas parce que d'une part
si on ne sait pas on prend évidemment le
risque de contaminer de personnes et
d'autre part vous serez vous pouvez
mourir demain quoi ouais c'est pas
dommage si
ces prix suffisamment tout c'est plus
facile à soigner bah oui parce que là
la trithérapie
existe alors on en guérit pas on ne
devient pas séronégatifs on
c'est pas ça ne perde ça ne donne pas la
possibilité de ne pas contaminer son
partenaire mai
ça marche ça fait diminuer le virus à
l'empêchent de progresser si jamais à un
moment donné ça marche ça marche plus il
ya d'autres médicaments à prendre donc
on peut tenir quand même quelques êtres
comme ça mais si on ne sait pas du tout
eh ben c'est ce que me disait rosenbaum
on en parle elle ya pas longtemps la
plupart des gens qui sont morts ce sont
des gens soient qui n'ont pas pris leur
traitement qu'ils ont mal pris ou alors
qu'ils ne l'ont jamais pris qui ne se
sont jamais fait dépister donc ils sont
arrivés et on ne pouvait plus rien faire
alors vous ce qui est incroyable c'est
que vous l'avez fait une première fois
le test à l'époque et puis vous étiez
vous étiez négatif quoi il est retourné
le faire quand même oui sur tourner le
fer dans quoi vous êtes retourné cg de
l'instinct ouais ouais
parce que j'ai des instincts et que
et que je l'avais déjà fait une fois
donc sam était quand même rester même si
à l'époque on savait pas trop ce que ça
voulait dire à part vivre deux ou trois
ans
qui nous restaient à vivre et je sortais
encore avec un garçon décidément il m'a
tiré qui se droguait donc
donc voilà donc je me suis dit c'est le
moment faut que j'y retourne ils y
apprennent les discriminations c'est à
dire que vous avez choisi à l'époque de
garder le silence parce que vous aviez
peur de ne plus travailler si ça se dit
ça se savait mon rendez même pas compte
mes parents qui m'ont dit garder le
silence moi j'étais trop naïf pour
penser ça m'empêcherait de travailler si
j'en parlais ouais
par contre mes parents ont bien fait de
me dire de garder le silence parce que
ce qui m'a tenu ces deux c'est de
travailler pendant quinze enfin d'avoir
toujours travailler et de ne pas en
parler
et voila quoi d'avoir une vie sociale il
ya une affaire de noce blanche avec jean
claude brisseau vous lui avez dit et il
l'a dit aux assureurs ces sales
histoires je lui dis à jean claude
brisseau en tout cas parce qu'on
répétait depuis pas mal de temps et que
j'avais besoin de lui dire je trouvais
que ça pouvait apporter au personnage et
on avait passé plusieurs semaines
ensemble donc j'étais voilà ce que mon
côté naïf et
il en a parlé en effet aux producteurs
et qui ont deux semaines avant se
déprendre quelqu'un d'autre ouais
aujourd'hui cette malade sur dix sont
victimes de discrimination ouais mais
justement c'est d'autant plus important
de ton plus grave d'empêcher les gens de
le dire parce que justement on prend
encore des risques de contaminer les
autres quand on a peur on le dit pas si
on le dit pas voilà on va contaminer si
on contamine l'autre va contaminer et
caetera et c'est un truc qui n'en finit
pas quoi donc il ya un moment donné
on est en 2006 il faut je sais pas ça ne
disparaîtra pas demain il est temps
d'accepter les gens comme ça ce ne sera
pas comme ça
voilà j'ai comme le cancer à une époque
on n'en parlait pas les gens qui avaient
le cancer on dise ne faisait pas trop en
parler et c'est râpé
alors le sidaction permet de soutenir la
recherche alors les progrès il ya la
pilule du lendemain quitte à prendre
pendant un mois
en cas de rapports à risque mais c'est
pas sûr à 100% donc c'est pas sûr à 100%
et en plus ça donne des effets
secondaires fade pour le coup pas drôle
du tout
donc vaut mieux éviter
et puis à l'injection la piqûre mensuel
qui remplacerait tous les médicaments
qu'on est obligé transmises via ce qu'on
attend ouais c'est existe pas encore ça
ah bon c'est nick zano quand c'est au
mieux ce qu'on attend non là ce qui peut
arriver ce qui peut se passer de mieux
pour nous et le vaccin n'y a pas de
piste pour le moment non
donc faut gagner du pognon ça n'existe
pas donc en effet en a besoin d'argent
pour la recherche pour aider ceux qui
sont malades parce que souvent ce sont
des gens qui sont seuls qui sont démunis
qui n'ont plus de travail
donc c'est pas normal et la recherche le
téléthon fait énormément d'argent le
sidaction n'en n'est absolument pas là
du tout alors qu'il en a
autant besoin
c'est fait
oh
c'est quelque chose à dire sur le sur le
sidaction sur le sida quand j'entends
que la guerre en irak coûte 200
milliards de dollars je suis halluciné
d'entendre qu'ils ont besoin d'argent
pour le sida mais c'est des gens foncent
une porte ouverte mais qu'est-ce que je
peux faire ouais en rire ou pleurer
voilà on essaie de faire les deux ouais
c'est décapoté épargné parents de les
mettre des parents de les acheter n'ayez
pas honte de les mettre et puis ya
beaucoup de plaisir gratuite finalement
ça faciliterait beaucoup de choses je
crois parce que ça coûte quand même très
cher ça fait partie du début de ce
siècle alors c'est vrai que ça va
forcément toujours très drôle mais
c'est faisable on va voir maintenant un
tableau d'olga car a dit moss qui est en
vente aux enchères sur le site du
sidaction rebecca ebala très bien
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc à l'adresse e-mail qu'il
passe au bas de l'écran magie de la
télévision donc voilà vous pouvez faire
vos enchères sur le site sidaction donc
voilà si quelqu'un veut acquérir une
toile du décor on voit des six nations
ah oui c'est vrai on peut vendre les
toits des écoles en lettonie décor
également 6 mai les auteurs en sont
d'accord bien ayant demandé voilà très
bien laurent bravo
la patrie j'oublie s'épiler merci à
marie avec nous
j'accueille jacques vergès
ça va très bien vous allez avoir la
forme ben oui qu'est boue pendant ses
huit ans
dans un spa
gestion récurrentes h du soir rien à ces
messieurs on ne saura jamais pas
peut-être si vous le dira un jour
peut-être quand même vous étiez là vous
marrer ou vous me dire à moi je me suis
arrêtée dans dix ans ouais mais qu'est
ce que vous faites là vous n'êtes pas
censé être un des avocats de saddam
hussein vous non j'ai été pressenti mais
après il ya eu toutes sortes de
d'événements une partie de la famille
m'a désigné une autre partie à désigner
d'autres confrères
et puis alors je me suis mise
de côté et puis finalement il n'a plus
que des avocats irakiens dont deux sont
morts un autre est à l'hopital nord est
en fuite a et c'est dangereux si bien
que certains disent tu as de la chance
ils sont morts de quoi ceux qui sont
morts d'origine immigrée et tu alors ils
ont été tués et a mis d'accord non
émis le cv qu'il a été tué ou pas alors
à votre avis moi je suis votre client
minos eric moi je suis persuadé qu'on
l'a pour la laisser mourir
vous savez on peut mourir de mort
naturelle provoquée je me rappelle
pendant la guerre d'algérie je défends
d'un homme sa famille vient me voir en
disant c'est urgent il a été arrêté ce
matin voyez vous agiter le monde entier
si vous voulez mais demain matin il peut
mourir jeudi de tortures made in hong il
est diabétique ouais si on lui fait pas
sa piqûre insuline chaque jour ils
crèvent
et ils meurent de mort naturelle
or ce type était très mal à tout le
monde en convient il a demandé à être
soigné en russie nous ne sommes plus au
temps de la guerre froide et les russes
avaient promis de le tenir la
disposition du tribunal on a refusé ce
qu'ils ont refusé cela porte la
responsabilité de cette mort ouais vous
dites aujourd'hui si les autorités
serbes accepté de livrer d'autres
nationaux ôtez pays elle porterait la
responsabilité de leur mort va bien sûr
il ya quatre serbes qui sont déjà morts
deux se sont suicidés dit on un autre
est mort de je ne sais trop quoi et puis
c'est le la est mort de mort prétendu
naturel c'est marrant ce tribunal quand
même c'est un tribunal curieux vous
savez que les magistrats dans ce
tribunal quand ils repèrent reçoivent
leur paye qui est assez importante
chaque mois 14% sont payés par des
particuliers ouais c'est à dire des
ennemis de la serbie dont monsieur soros
ah oui que diriez vous si vous deviez
comparer devant un tribunal en france en
apprenant que monsieur x patron de
l'aviation pay pay pour ça et monsieur x
qui est là le roi de la chaîne une
chaîne de supermarchés paye également
vous dire que le tribunal international
de la haye est financé par des fonds
privés pour quatorze courses toréables
ça
arrive c'est pas ben je vous l'apprends
paraît surréaliste ça vous dit c'est un
tribunal d assassin et bien écoutez
quand on laisse mourir quelqu'un
volontairement on est un assassin pas
aux termes juridiques précis mais dans
le langage courant soit 111 est pas une
haute opinion de la justice et c'est ce
qui apparaît une fois de plus à la
lecture de votre nouveau livre jacques
vergès qui s'appelle mallard aux pauvres
oui qui est publié chez plon par le
pitch est très simple c'est la justice à
deux vitesses
et vous prenez un certain nombre
d'exemples qui illustrent votre thèse
effectivement je peux vous ordonnez
qu'on soit puissant ou misérable alors
on va commencer avec la sphère des
disparues de l'yonne la sphère d'emile
louis
la première disparition ait lieu 27 ans
avant que la justice n'enquête
malgré le dossier du gendarme jambert
qui lui aussi en deux mois trop tard il
veut se suicider ou sur la suicidée et
quand on l'a retrouvé le dossier du
gendarme jambert donc il y avait écrit
non donc dessus comme ça sur le rapport
voilà alors est ce qu il a été protégé
par de puissants pédophiles régionaux
c'est possible vous savez qu avant cette
affaire il ya eu un type qui avait été
arrêté
sur flagrant délit dans sa cave y avait
une fille nue attachées à une croix de
saint-andré et à côté il y avait un
tarif un coup de canif dans le sens
étant un coup de canif plus basse étant
et ce type a été arrêté dix ans du
vernet au jour d'hui mais la liste des
clients a disparu ouais
et vous avez dansé disparues de l'yonne
de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit de pauvre
fille un peu retardé des villes légère
débile légère confié à la dass dire à
l'assistance publique alors elles
disparaissent au fur et à mesure et on
doit s'emparer c'est pour ça on écrit
sur leur fiche fugue si c'était la fille
d'un avocat d'un médecin d'un
journaliste on n'aurait pas mis fugue on
aurait cherché et là pendant 27 ans mais
je trouve vraiment si c'était toujours
dans le même département vers des mêmes
chaussures
etc et vous mais je parle de ça mais en
ce moment à toulouse vous avez 27
prostituées au passé de 7 à l'école des
call girls c'est des prostituées de
trottoir elles sont mortes et sur la
fiche de chacune on a écrit suicide
l'une s'est suicidé par ce procédé très
habituel la licence libre dans sa bouche
en se cassant une dent est assez ouvert
la gorge qu'un couteau ce qui est la
manière la plus habituelle des
universités chez les femmes mais
pourquoi parce que ces deux pauvres
prostituées de trottoir ouais
alors nous raconter l'histoire du
japonais cannibale a le japonais
cannibale c'est un type qui était
étudiant japonais à paris qui est
repoussé par une hollandaise de 25 ans
ça lui plaît pas du tout il la tue il la
mange il a fait cuire par morceau à la
poêle et ensuite il met un peu de
moutarde un peu de un peu de sel ou
appuient ce régal ce japonais cannibale
et bien en fait c'était le fils d'un
patron important
japonais 1 et ça coïncidait avec la
visite du premier ministre japonais en
france voilà il fallait pas
abîmer les relations commerciales entre
la france et le japon et ce type s'est
facilement fait passer pour un fou oui
il est resté un an à l'hôpital de
villejuif ensuite il est parti au japon
il a été libéré un an et demi après et
depuis il est devenu un personnage
célèbre théoricien du cannibalisme un
héros artistique il finit pas
il devenu une star quoi là-bas c'est ça
et il a publié le récit de ses repas en
disant que le sein à la poêle ca diminué
de volume ses escales bon il ya des
femmes et c'est devenu un roi de l'an
dernier acte donne une personnalité et
vous dites d'ailleurs quand 92 on a
retrouvé le corps d'une femme coupée en
morceaux près de chez lui alors on l'a
pas accuser vraiment mais enfin on peut
penser que vu l'impunité dont il jouit
il continua c'est sûr ouais on parlait
de faire un outil al'inverse alors lui
il été guillotiné à 22 ans
après une enquête et une instruction ou
tout ce qui pouvait mettre en doute sa
culpabilité a été écartée à commencer
par le fameux pull-over rouge dont on a
tant parlé qu'il ne lui appartenait pas
et qu'on a retrouvé sur le lieu du crime
quoi le frère de la petite
fille qui a été tuée de l'or a reconnu
adhap 17 définit la voiture
et c'est pas la voiture de christian
ranucci il y avait un type qui avait
beaucoup plus grand plus âgé qu un
pull-over rouge qui rôdait dans le coin
les plaintes des parents n'ont pas été
versées dans le dossier et lui alors lui
rapidement pour découper le coup pour
coup jusqu'à l'infini cinq ans
sabu demander ça à giscard j'aimerais
pas être à sa place c'est notre ami la
pression de l'opinion grand palais de la
sphère des frégates de taïwan en ça
c'est énorme on a beaucoup parlé ici
avec christine deviers-joncour on a
parlé aussi avec le juge jean-pierre
paix à son âme donc si la sphère des
commissions illégales versées pour
modifier la position du gouvernement
français sur la vente de frégates à
taïwan et c'est en fait la vraie affaire
derrière la sphère elle alors
ce qui est incroyable ce que vous
préciser dans votre bouquin d'ailleurs
c'est que l' affaire n'aurait pas éclaté
si alfred sirven n'avait pas saisi le
tribunal arbitral
m quand thompson a refusé de payer des
commissions père a commis si thomson
avait payé les commissions qu'ils
avaient promis aux gens on en aurait
jamais rien dessus déjà c'est énorme et
la deuxième chose énorme c'est ce que
juge jean pierre nous a souvent répété
ici c'est que tout ça est protégé par le
secret défense dire qu'aujourd'hui on
sait qu'il ya des gens ont touché les
commissions sur les frégates de taïwan
la liste existe quelque part mais on ne
peut pas la sortir parce que tous les
gouvernements ont d'ailleurs de droite
comme de gauche ont mis ça secret
défense riz en plus il ya quatre morts
dans cette affaire ouais
il ya des gens des services de taiwan et
des gens des services français qui meurt
et qui meurt comment quand ils ouvrent
leurs fenêtres le vent souffle trop fort
et y tombe avec inscrivent dans la
bouche un autre type est noyé il est
mort noyé on regarde dans ses poumons
n'y a pas d'eau
un autre type meurt dans sa baignoire
avec des ecchymoses sur le visage
le secret défense a été défendu avec
beaucoup de conscience
voter blanc ce qui est incroyable
jacques c'est quand on parle à la
télévision nous ici on m'a parlé dix
fois on dit à la télévision il ya des
des gens du personnel politique ont
touché des commissions etc on en parle
on a le droit de le dire marquer on
n'est pas en russie soviétique en même
temps la loi de le dire mais ça s'arrête
là turckheim voilà le chemin comme
johnny ce but encaissé on lui dit ah ben
non secret défense c'est extraordinaire
seulement se fout de la gueule des gens
étaient tous les gouvernement invoque
son secret défense si oui qui dure
combien de temps qui peut durer tout le
temps tout le temps y'a pas une date de
péremption de ce nom dans 50 ans quand
tout le monde sera mort 1 on va dire la
vérité c'est comme pour si ce n'est
qu'on envisage maintenant là
la révision il ya plus aucun survivant
ouais ouais
lorsque vous dites aussi concernant la
sphère des vedettes de taiwan c'est
qu'au final c'est le contribuable qui va
payer parce que les taiwanais eux ils
veulent les taiwanais les français il ya
un contrat avec eux il est prévu que
dans ce contrat qui aura pas de pot de
vin
l'épreuve il pots-de-vin existe on ne
sait pas à qui il a profité mais ils
existent et les taïwanais actuellement
introduit une procédure
pour en dommages et intérêts des
manifestions c'est vous c'est moi qui
allons payer notre code pin pour payer
cela tandis que le type qui s'est rempli
les poches il nous regarde en l'air de
dire cause toujours tu m'intéresses ni
peut-être en train de nous regarder un
et ils se marrent tête même qui est sur
le plateau
laurent b dans la liste
alors vous raconter plein d'histoires
effectivement au service de votre thèse
c'est à dire la justice des pauvres la
justice des riches c'est pas du tout la
même justement les différences de
traitement par exemple entre la sphère
caroline dickinson et la sphère omar
haddad sur l'utilisation des résultats
des analyses adn vous dites dans la
sphère raddad la piste pouvait mener à
un proche de madame marchal un homme du
monde un homme d'en haut
il y à une même pas une étudiante une
écolière anglaise magasin dickinson et
violée et tuée dans une auberge de
jeunesse la nuit dans un dortoir
le juge andrew peck a fait 3600 relevé
d'adr
à la fin on a trouvé le meurtrier sur
une route de dans l'île de ré au mois
d'août pendant les vacances la petite
audrey et violée et tuée à 12h30
la police et les juges en chercher tout
ce qui était susceptible de passer sur
cette route au mois d'août deux cents
personnes on appris de ses 200 personnes
leur adn et on a trouvé la salsa dans la
sphère omar haddad à ma demande la
commission de révision analyse de taches
de sang edit et l'expertisé ces deux
tâches sont
du sang de madame marchal mais dans
chacune des tâches et un adn d'hommes et
ces deux adn sur différents entre eux
est différent de celui de bagdad alors
moi je dis il faut il faut continuer la
caudrévision dit non on peut pas de
dater la dnp dans la sphère des petits
dickinson ne pouvait pas datées non plus
ni dans la sphère des îles de ré et il
est rentré beaucoup de monde dans sa
cave dans la cave d'une villa cossue à
mougins il hante moins de monde que dans
une auberge de jeunesse ou sur une route
en plein été
mais quelle est la différence la
différence est que le type qui viole une
fille une écolière dans une auberge de
jeunesse la nuit en dépit de la levée
juste un geste de fou star ou tard on
peut le chercher le trouver non celui
qui fait la même chose sur une route à
12h30 dans les degrés c'est également un
irresponsable
on peut le trouver sa route art mais
dans la cave dire que les domestiques et
les habits de la maison si c'est pas le
domestique qui sait
circulez ya rien à voir yann adn de
pauvres on peut chercher et un adn de
riches ça on n'y touche pas
mais
toujours été comme ça de tous temps vous
semble étonner il fut un temps où
d'affirmer d'inégalité des gens y
avaient privilégié des aristos les
roturiers aujourd'hui on nous dit les
droits de l'homme nous sommes tous égaux
et en fait aujourd'hui plus que jamais
ça existe c'est cette discrimination est
ce que je dis là en dénonçant ces pour
que l'opinion parfois aidé à elle est
abusée par les grands discours vous avez
par exemple dans l' affaire d'outreau il
ya un juge qu'on appelle le juge des
libertés
on a créé le juge des libertés dans le
monde voyez on s'intéresse à des
libertés il ya la présomption
d'innocence et le juge des libertés
quand il était entendu par la commission
dit moi je connais pas le dossier j'ai
pas le dossier j'ai pas le type en face
de moi et puis je suis débordée ben
alors je donne raison au juge je lui
fais confiance d'un collègue un médecin
qui dirait je suis fatigué j'ai bossé 10
heures ce jour-là je peux en faire la
preuve est à deux heures du matin quand
on m'a appelé pour cette femme qui a
accouché eh ben je me suis rendormi mais
ce mec il est poursuivi
j'ai vu un geste malheureux
chez plon et l'apprécier
[Musique]
interview 4 conscience
jacques vergès avez vous déjà trouvé la
justice juste oui parfois oui parfois
quand ça ne met pas en cause des
intérêts trop important quand le
la personne qui réclame justice un
certain poids oui ça arrive
mais cela devrait être la règle n'est
pas la règle avez vous déjà eu envie de
perdre un procès non avez vous déjà
trouvé que le réquisitoire du procureur
contre un nouveau client était trop
sympa trop sympa
ça m'est jamais arrivé avez vous déjà
fait innocente et un coupable
ah oui peut-être non non
vous êtes vous fait plus fort que je ne
suis vous êtes un essor où il était
spécialisé dans les fumiers quand même
tout le monde a un droit à un avocat et
fumiers absolument jeu mais de là à les
faire innocenter
un coupable est innocenté ou c'est la
faute de qui du procureur qui n'a pas
été à la hauteur
nous avons dans un processus en
orchestre l'avocat est là pour trouver
tous les arguments de la défense le
broker est là pour trouver tous les
arguments de l'accusation si le
procureur ne les a pas trouvés alors que
c'était visible vous ai pas rendre
l'avocat responsable dans un orchestre
si le violoniste joue mal vous rendrez
pas le pianiste responsable lui qui joue
bien du piano mais au cours d'une
instruction vous rendez compte que le
type ou qu'elle vous croyez innocence et
qu'en fait tu es coupable comment vous
réagissez par rapport à ça vous pouvez
vous des maîtres du dossier alors qu'on
sait bien sûr c'est que le type est
coupable oui c'est vrai que souvent je
les dis quand on voit notre client
partir entre deux gendarmes on se dit
est il vraiment coupable esch mal plaidé
mais parfois quand on le voit sortir
libre en faisant comme ça on se dit est
il vraiment innocent bien plaidé avez
vous déjà été embêté quand un coupable
vous a demandé de le défendre non quand
c'était des politiques il reconnaissait
ce qu'il avait fait et moi je n'y ai pas
quand c'est des droits communs sur le
type ne le dit pas est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait exprès d'être mauvais pour
perdre en procès non est-ce que vous
avez déjà pensé qu'un de vos clients
méritait une peine plus lourde que celle
qu'il a eue oui bien sûr
avez vous déjà menti devant un tribunal
non menteur
on a donné parce que si on ment c'est
dangereux et on vous prend le la main
dans le truc
efforts
devraient faire un vocable avez vous
déjà eu du mal à croiser le regard d'une
victime donne vos clients
non non parce que j'ai rien contre
victimes
j'ai déjà été heureux d'être détesté
saab est indifférent vous ai déjà
détesté être heureux ah non jamais être
heureux et je suis heureux
c'est un tempérament bon le temps je me
lève le matin que je m'étire je suis
follement de repères
est-ce que vous avez déjà été nu sous
votre homme nu ses marottes
donc ça c'est visible
jacques vergès
bon
et c touarga
une carte
et la lire
car les quatre procureurs vous devez
faire un réquisitoire contre maître
vergès alors je dois le faire oui ou de
dire du mal de vergès écoutez je vous
demande de condamner maître vergès parce
que ce type est impossible ça ce qui
n'est pas fréquent tard je plais les 60
passionnante ce type n'est jamais
d'accord avec l'accusation ce type
relèvent toutes les failles de
l'accusation
ce type nous prend pour des cons et ce
type nous ridiculisent c'est pas
possible
vous voulez mais bien bergès dupontel je
le connais assez peu pour dire ça mais
je serai le personnage charismatique et
impressionnant bon dieu d'un côté je
vous dis comme je le pense mais je le
connais mal j'ai des excuses voilà
merci d'avoir été avec nous en tous les
cas merci que l'ancien finalement
j'accueille astrid veillon
[Musique]
astrid veillon
bonsoir ça va ça va très bien alors vous
reprenez les monologues du vagin au
petit théâtre de paris à partir du 4
avril avec sara giraudeau et isabelle
aubret
alors les interprètes change
régulièrement mais cette pièce d'eve
ensler a déjà connu en france 1800
représentation et 500 mille spectateurs
qui l'ont vu aussi bien ce qui était
créé à new york à partir de témoignages
de femmes du monde entier sur leur sexe
et l'objectif c'était de donner aux
vagins la reconnaissance qui lui
manquait pour ça surréaliste
mais c'est une façon imagée de dire ça
oui c'est surtout un hymne à la femme je
pense dans l'idée de faire peut-être
donner un côté un peu libérateur un des
femmes qui ont vécu des choses plus ou
moins violentes ouais je sais que
d'après ce que j'ai pu lire après les
représentations eve ensler a eu beaucoup
de témoignages de femmes qui avaient
subi des violences qu'avait été violé et
ç'avait été une façon pour elle de
pouvoir se dire je suis pas la seule je
peux en parler librement vous l'avez vu
non on connaît les airs jacques oui oui
non mais je suis convaincu
les interprètes changent mais le vagin
reste le même
alors que des nains vous étiez sur scène
c'était à marigny oui avec alain delon
les montagnes russes alors vous regardez
un bon souvenir excellent mais pourtant
vous n'êtes pas parti en tournée
pourquoi pas parce que j'étais
extrêmement fatigué le rôle était été
très fatigante 13 heures un temps je
jouais cinq personnages en 1h50 je
finissais par un monologue de dix
minutes c'était l'histoire d'une d'une
femme qui retrouvait son père qui
l'avait abandonné donc ça fait peut-être
ressurgir des choses chez moi et c'est
vrai que pendant les dix minutes moi je
suis quelqu'un qui n'a pas de technique
donc quand je vais pleurer je me faire
du mal et quand on va se faire du mal
tous les soirs pendant cinq mois
automatiquement il ya ça joue un peu sur
eux sur le cerveau donc j'ai fini très
très très éprouvés et j'ai effectivement
refusé de faire la tournée oui vous avez
dit alain est formidable il est très
directif
il est du genre à décider tout seul sans
m'en parler avant qu'est ce qu'il a
décidé tout seul sans vous en parler
avant non mais c'est vrai que alain est
quelqu'un qui qui a l'habitude de gérer
sa vie et les gens qui sont autour de
lui moi je devais tourner que numéro 1
derrière le dernier épisode et c'est
vrai qu'il arrivait avec à chaque fois
d'autres dates et je le disais à l'un et
à un moment il faut me concerter parce
que je peux pas à chaque fois décalé les
tournages et ses deux passes et une
anecdote je sais pas fallu demander
ouais ça plombe ont ils fait pour toi
vous supportez pas comment piètre sur
votre liberté
non c'est vrai que j'ai du mal j'ai un
rapport avec ma liberté qui est un peu
excessif et peut-être qu'ils m'empêchent
d'être vraiment libre a essayé quelqu'un
qui empiète sur votre liberté en ce
moment en ce moment non je me sens très
très libre ah ouais ou peut-être non non
non non non
des fidèles en ce moment oui tout va
bien le contente
entre regrets radieuse bah je suis dans
une bonne période de ma vie j'ai un peu
mort fait il n'ya pas longtemps et puis
j'ai quand on quand on voit là quand on
vit des choses pas très facile les mains
du coup ça nous permet de relativiser
sur pas mal de choses et puis c'est vrai
que je fais des choix qui me plaisent
surtout au niveau de mon boulot et du
coup moins ça me donne une certaine
liberté d'être de penser avec des choix
qui sont qui me ressemble donc du coup
je me sens ouais pas mal en accord avec
moi-même tout va bien vous avez d'être
sereine quoi sereine
de temps en temps aujourd'hui vous vivez
au bord de la marne calmement
je peux aller crier votre vincennes
canton m'énerve les romans policiers
alors j'ai envie d'écrire c'est la salle
de bains a été le déclencheur de sa
j'avoue que maintenant j'ai un petit peu
peur de me remettre la peur de ne pas y
arriver il ya d'autres pièces après peu
ça a été déjà fait et
qu'est ce que je disais donc j'ai fait
le sénat j'ai fait le scénario du fait
du mieux j'ai fait le scénario donc
j'étais capable de le faire et
effectivement j'ai envie d'écrire un
bouquin qui est sûr
sur une femme qui a pas mal de soucis
une actrice de 36 ans qui se suicide oui
voilà et pour plaindre de plein de
raisons donc je suis en train d'écrire
une histoire comme ça après un talk show
se suicident comment être mais pas un
string dans la bouche en souvent ingrat
ça fait rigoler les bleus font rire
j'avais cru crouler de rire
c'est vrai qu'ils terre au japon pendant
huit ans
juste avec moi même je mets ou
géographiquement ou sur quel continent
ça dépend où
on va l'avoir à l'usure non regardez moi
vous étiez aux compotes pain au cambodge
à il achète du temps à venir aux
hypothèses sont possibles donc tant que
grand qu'un café veux c'est que ça veut
dire oui
[Musique]
interview monologue
alors est ce que vous êtes déjà dit mais
qu'est ce que je fous à parler de ma
chatte là depuis une heure maintenant
parce que j'ai pas encore joué a donc
j'attaque mardi donc on se reverra pour
en parler d'accord et si vous êtes déjà
dit si armande altaï est arrivé je vais
y arriver
non parce que je pense que toutes les
femmes qui sont concernés par par la
cause féminine et par qui sont touchés
par tout ce qu'on peut voir dans le
monde encore aujourd'hui dès l'instant
où il ya une vraie envie une âme je
pense que on peut on peut le jouer même
si un vrai travail de comédienne c'est
surtout un texte qui est mis en avant là
d'un talent donc donc voilà est ce que
j'ai déjà dit les moches mais bon il est
producteur
c'est pas le genre de choses que je me
dis non non non
si vous êtes déjà dit lui sait où il
veut quand il veut oui surtout la
tournée
je vous ai déjà dit tiens ce soir je
joue comme une saucisse oui oui ça m'est
arrivé ben notamment avec avec delon les
premières représentations j'étais
tellement impressionné de me retrouver
sur scène au marigny avec lui et des
fois j'avais carrément ddd regarder je
vous dis mais qu'est ce que je fous là
et j'avais un peu des absents soit là je
sortais en scène pas très contente de
moi oui si vous êtes déjà dit elle est
trop bien gaulée vahina giocante c'est
dégueulasse non j'aime les belles femmes
ouais j'aime les belles femmes à elle
est excessive mont-joli ouais
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit justement
avec une fille ça doit être pas mal oui
mais alors
eh bien alors je j'aime les hommes
je vous ai déjà dit non 5 dans un seul
lycée
et
je me suis pas dit ça parce que je ne me
suis jamais retrouvé dans ce genre de
situation vous ai déjà dit aujourd'hui
la france demain le monde quand j'étais
petit et que j'avais plein de plaindre
alors les aime dans la tête trouvait
certainement la danse finisse maintenant
j'ai envie de me faire plaisir et j'ai
envie de jouer des rôles qui me king qui
me plaisent dans lequel je m'éclate et
et voilà c'est ma première première
raison mais si vous êtes déjà dit j'ai
envie de mourir oui l'a longtemps pas
spécialement
au bailleur
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit et si je
faisais la ferme célébrités l'année
prochaine non peut-être dans dix ans je
vous tiendrais pas le même discours pour
l'instant non si vous êtes déjà dit
allez hop au régime magros oui
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit je tuerai
pour ce rôle non est ce que vous êtes
déjà dit mais qu'est ce qu'elle a de
plus que moi nicole kidman
nom pareil je trouve que c'est une
actrice sublime qui est en plus
magnifiquement belle et keller
intelligente donc non je peux avoir de
l'admiration pour ce genre de femme est
ce que vous êtes déjà dit elle aussi
juste un porno personnes le saura
non non non est ce que vous êtes déjà
dit et si je prenais des cours de
comédie pour un porno je vois qu'on met
justement moi je me suis longtemps
considéré et puis même encore maintenant
d'ailleurs comme une sorte
d'arrivistes dans ce métier parce qu'il
ya tellement de gens qui ont fait le
conservatoire fait des cours de théâtre
etc moi je suis arrivé par les sites
comme on m'a prise parce que je
ressemblais au personnage qui était
décrite dans la bible et donc voilà au
fur et à mesure j'ai appris à force de
tournage etc et une fois je me suis dit
enfin à plusieurs reprises mais bon une
fois qui m'a marqué je me dis bon
visiblement tu as quelque chose à faire
là dedans
tu as un peu de chance parce qu'il faut
un peu de chance si tout ça s'en va il
faudrait peut-être que tu es un peu de
technique donc j'ai voulu prendre des
cours de théâtre est encore plus forte
de cela je suis retourné sur un plateau
avec un réalisateur avec qui j'avais
déjà travaillé et on a commencéà action
j'ai commencé à faire ma scène et l'
uvre les coupes est venu me voir et me
dit mais qu'est ce que tu fais g milan
mais parce qu'au cours on m'a dit moi je
dis bon allez je vais arrêter les cours
c'est pas votre truc quoi mais
j'apprends et puis je vois là c'est à
l'instant avoue tout à l'instinct
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit si je me
faisais refaire les seins pas encore non
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit tiens il
est plus beau au cinéma à lui voit la
télé way émergence et les mieux en vrai
[Musique]
j'ai audio
gravité ce soir
un toit en choeur
trop vite car tes fantasmes vous devez
vous nous raconter votre dernier rêve
érotique voilà
manque de chance nettement en plus je
n'ai absolument aucune mémoire de mes
rêves
si ce n'est le dernier que j'ai eu une
était pas du tout un rêve érotique mais
c'était un monsieur qui vendait des
boules avec des enfants dedans et j'ai
volé donc c'est peut-être le plein de
symboles derrière tout ça j'ai volé un
oeuf comme ça et après tout peu notre
jeu dit je suis désolée j'ai volé un
oeuf alors c'était fait pour des femmes
qui pouvaient pas avoir d'enfant fin de
leur rêve être très compliqué il le mec
m'a dit mais toute façon il était pour
vous voilà c'est le dernier rêve que
j'ai faits dont je me souviens en tout
cas vous 100 g la maternité en ce moment
non bah oui mais c'est normal je vais
avoir 30 50 et oui vous allez trouver le
mec je sais pas il a rencontré hier
laissent leur un peu de temps
[Musique]
j'accueille philippe tesson et jean
françois kahn
son hit organise sa valeur actuelle
critique dramatique au figaro magazine
directeur de l'avant scène théâtre
chroniqueur culturel dans diverses
émissions jean françois kahn fondateur
de marianne président du conseil
d'administration de marianne et ça voilà
alors vous pensez quoi de ce cpe
philippe vous pensez que c'est un un
contrat de travail unique est unique en
europe où un mal nécessaire compte tenu
de la situation de l'emploi des jeunes
moi j'étais pour le cp oui moi je suis
j'étais et je suis encore pour tout ce
qui peut déverrouiller les obstacles qui
se dressent contre l'emploi n'importe
quoi tout pourvu que les jeunes trouvent
dans les meilleures conditions le plus
ou dans les plus mauvaises conditions
mais le plus vite possible un emploi
cela dit la sphère a été très bon à la
manche est très mal géré je trouve que
villepin était très maladroit au point
que je on peut se demander s'il ne l'a
pas fait exprès c'est à dire s'il ne
veut pas provoquer dans le pays une
épreuve de force faire péter les choses
parce qu'il faudra bien que les choses
peuvent un jour c'est sûr la france
pourra pas rester à la situation dans
laquelle elle est éternellement je vois
déjà jean-françois ricaner mais ça n'est
pas possible la france ne pourra pas
vivre longtemps encore la façon dont
elle vit il faudra que la crise un jour
est plate 1 seulement quand on veut
faire éclater la crise comme l'avait
fait margaret thatcher en son temps en
angleterre les préparer il faut préparer
le terrain il faut préparer l'opinion il
faut avoir une assise non seulement une
assise parlementaire mais une assise
psychologique une assise populaire au
meilleur des cas ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui en france voilà alors je
trouve que il est allé trop loin et je
regrette que chirac et épousé son point
de vue car je crois que le risque que
prend le gouvernement dans cette affaire
c'est à dire le risque d'une crise et ne
sera néfaste à l'intérêt général et
peut-être même néfaste à l'intérêt de
tous les acteurs du drame aussi bien les
syndicats
qui ne doivent pas croire qu'ils s'en
tireront un thème du conflit qui
risquent de surgir et la jeunesse et
surtout la jeunesse dont il est vrai que
l'enjeu essentiel de toute cette affaire
c'est quand même la jeunesse son
équilibre son avenir or la jeunesse
c'est quand même c'est très respectable
mais c'est très incontrôlable et est
aujourd'hui tout le monde est à la
traîne de la jeunesse et c'est ça c'est
là où est la gravité de la crise
8 et pau aux comptes vous au départ
non comme patron je suis vachement pour
autant prendre un employé pouvoir le
prendre et le virer quand on veut ce
formidable marque et ne pas le payer du
tout c'est encore mieux pour un patron
j'aimerais beaucoup mais comme citoyen
je trouve que c'est très difficile c'est
inacceptable pour un jeune ça mais vous
savez moi j'ai je vais vous dire et
quand quand on étudie jeu le l'histoire
de france c'est très intéressant parce
qu'on remarque une chose c'est que toute
l'histoire de france est ponctuée
toujours par un événement si à un moment
il ya une régression de trop series on a
l'impression qu'ils se passe rien que
tout est éternel et puis il ya une
régression toujours par exemple je
prends un seul exemple quand vous avez
le règne de louis-philippe sa durée 18
ans à 18 ans et argue un peu comme ça à
conservateur et c'est vrai que bombay se
passait rien c'était d'un calme
absolument limpide l'impression que
c'était éternel ça allait jamais changé
bon on et revenait sur toutes les
promesses qu'on avait faite au début sur
les acquis mais bon il ya une espèce de
fatalisme c'est comme ça on peut rien
faire ça bougera pas etc et puis un jour
vous avez des gens qui ont dit que tu
allais il ya 350 mille personnes
seulement qu'en droit de voter mais qui
sont très riches c'est quand même pas
beaucoup si on portait sa 450 milles
extremis alors dit non pas question et
c'est alors ils disent on va protester
mais à l'époque on pouvait pas faire de
meeting on pouvait pas manifester dans
la rue on avait le droit simplement de
deux bouffées ensemble ça on pouvait pas
interdire alors les types il décide de
faire des bancaires ils se réunissent
autour d'une table ils bouffent du
poulet et banquets et 10 c'est une rente
le pouvoir et tout ça tout le monde s'en
fout franchement c'est pas pas ça qui va
ébranler le régime donc va et puis en
début février c'est terminé ils ont fini
leur banquet et à ce moment là le
pouvoir tellement sûr de lui-même de que
c'est ces connards qu'est-ce que deux
pour qu'ils prennent match là on est
puissant il décide d'interdire le
dernier banquet qui était qui et aux
champs elysées et c'était la goutte
d'eau c'était le truc de trop tout on
sait pas pourquoi canon ah non quand
même ça même même un banquet entre nous
même ça on peut pas alors là c'est trop
et et voilà il ya une révolution il ya
eu des barricades et la monarchie était
renversée et la république a été
proclamée alors je dis pas qu'on en est
là mais je crois que c'est très
intéressant parce que toute l'histoire
et je pense que au delà de ce que c'est
c'est pas c'est pas scandale total le
cpe c'est pas c'est pas l'esclave et
gilles c'est pas l'horreur mais venant
après c'est la régression de trop et les
jeunes et tout le monde dans une société
impossible que personne accepte aussi
demandé à temps demander s'il ya une
chose que je trouve incroyable je lis
des temps les dans les articles
j'entends des commentateurs d'ailleurs
c'est toujours le même partout les mêmes
mots les mêmes phrases on croirait les
communistes il ya 50 ans une mécanique
ça sort d'une machine avec regarder les
gens qui manifestent sont des
conservateurs y sont attachés à leur
statut quo alors conservatrice mais
c'est tout il écrit tous pareils les
mêmes mots très bien s'est montré à quel
point les décideurs sont coupés de la
société parce que c'est pas que les gens
ne veulent pas bouger c'est pas qu'ils
veulent pas le statu quo mais attendez
il voit il voit il voit quoi il voit par
exemple que pendant ce temps la roue des
grands patrons ce vote des des
augmentations de salaire de 80 % ils
voient que pour gagner ce que certains
gagnent il faut un ouvrier avoir
travaillé depuis clovis depuis clovis
ils regardent ils voient qu'un type le
jeu de la description la description de
la société par jean rolin kbc vrai nom
mais regarder les choses en face le
patron d'air france sauf pendant trois
ans de 83% quand les grandes sociétés
les 40 pour plus grandes sociétés de
france reconnaît sans façon constante
d'annoncer à des profits de
83 milliards d'euros moi je suis patron
ce formidable et profite pas qu'aux
autres les gens sont pas quand mais
qu'est ce qu'ils apprennent que ça va
pas la croissance que ça va pas la
recherche que ça va pas à l'emploi ça va
au dans la poche des actionnaires des
fonds de pension et cetera et cetera des
îles ce vote des des retraites chapeaux
mais de maharaja bien dijon vient
d'apprendre et un type tiens quand on
vient d'apprendre qu'il a dû il a cumulé
23 milliards il a une richesse de 23
milliards en france bernard arnault je
suis très content pour lui ça représente
un million d'années de travail non mes
amis nous reçoit alors que ce joli mais
non mais les sacrifices pour tout le
monde je sais que ça vous gêne c'est le
gros choc je sais que les retours le
partage mais pourquoi partager mais
c'est pas que les sacs rick que tout on
ne peut pas à toi ça ne fait pas la fois
dire vous fait des sacrifices vous là la
précarité et c'est assez légitime et en
même temps les gens voient qu'en haut on
veut pas partie on reste en place on
s'accroche à son fauteuil au souk menthe
c'est pas possible
mais regarder les choses en face ce
n'est pas aussi ses vols ben oui mais
enfin c'est quand même un discours
simplificateur et populiste enfin pour
ce contre quoi je lis je veux pas dire
je veux pas dire démagogiquement fait
aujourd'hui on en est quand même pas
loin prison d'en distinguer en
distançant répond à mes draps tic c'est
pas mal en même temps tu dis que tu es
ghazi pour bernardo qui gagnent de
l'argent moi je dis non à une non
seulement bernard d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas contre ce ne sont pas les salariés
de bernard arnault qui battent le pavé
actuellement les salariés de bernard
arnault il se félicite que bernard
arnault exista doit pas être la nôtre on
de tension ça n'existe plus à ce niveau
là on n'est pas un mauvais patrons s'en
mettent plein les poches après tout ça
toujours été ainsi dans la vie non pas
depuis la monarchie de juillet mais
depuis la préhistoire a toujours été ça
tu sais que je peux remonter encore plus
loin en matière historique atteint en
suisse et la présidence
voilà
verra nos produits du travail il produit
des emplois de toute façon jean françois
on nous le savons très bien nous sommes
dans un système qui est un système
incontournables comme on dit aujourd'hui
qui est un système capitaliste est un
système libéral capitaliste auquel nous
avons intérêt à nous adapter et c'est
vrai que le problème français il répond
n'est pas celui de l'inégalité il est
celui du retard pris par la france dans
l'adhésion à ce système tu répondras à
mamma roma
votre wii les sacrifices lui l'erreur tu
peux pas dire aux gens oui à des
sacrifices et il faut faire des
sacrifices louis et cetera oui il faut
serrer la ceinture si tu as l'impression
qu'il ya des gens qui non seulement n'en
font pas mais ces mêmes l'averse c'est
pas possible franchement sans compter je
peux ajouter l'absence compter que c'est
une société où il n'y a que le fric
l'argent le le profit le pouvoir la
puissance gagner le plus vite possible
qu'est-ce que ça produit ça produit des
youssouf fofana parce que voilà des gens
qui veulent du pognon du payant tout de
suite toutes ces photos
moi j'ai vu l'autre jour qu'il y avait
la manifestation comme cette place de la
république et qu'on a notre journal et
place des arts et puis j'ai vu les
jeunes casseurs les bandes et j'ai
essayé d'écouter ce qu'ils disaient
c'était formidable il disait comme vous
parlez pas ligne avait dit être abordée
alors d'accord d'abord c'était d'abord
c'était débile il paraît avec 4 phrase
débile oui leur obsession c'est le
pognon là les rumeurs la loi de l'argent
s'était cassé le jeu s'est réduit de ce
système que tu défends mais si je vais
aussi déduit c'est également l'obsession
d'arnaud c'est l'obsession de tout être
humain
non c'est pourquoi je dis que le
discours et simplificateur astrid ccpl
et je pense qu'effectivement le cpe
c'est c'est une goutte qui fait déborder
le vase et c'est une vraie crise et que
ce soit sociale que ce soit économique
on est en train d'étouffer la classe
moyenne en france
ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est agir
c'est un constat que je fais en lisant
en regardant comme tout le monde mais
tout ça reflète un vrai mal être et il
faut faire quelque chose il faut que
voilà il faut arrêter d'être immobile
dans sa tronche et il faut écouter les
choses pourquoi pas les essayer le cpe
où j'en sais rien mais on est viré
n'importe quoi enfin tout le monde est
viré plus ou moins s'il ya des gens à
certains niveaux qui sont
malheureusement je lui dirai en banlieue
qui le soir
été commises les présidents des mêmes
ddd chez des gens qui à 80 ans sont
encore sénateur
fait le patron de presse patron d'un
esprit joyeux ce que je peux dire à
force de tenir ce discours là tu
entretiens cette île religion qui est
une illusion coupable j'allais dire
criminel qui fait croire aux jantes el
baile vaut un tel et que et elle mérite
le sort qui est réservé à la aux autres
je crois que le propre de tir m les
méchants mais c'est ça que tu fais
croire bonjour le golan commencer par
ceux ci c'est d'ailleurs le problème des
jeunes c'est parce que ce sont les
jeunes qui sont à cause de gens dit
c'est ça qui est grave dans ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est que ce soient
les lycéens et les collégiens et les
collégiens s'étaient dit que c'est
criminel de la part de la classe
politique française d'avoir pendant si
longtemps entretenu et pas seulement les
politiques d'ailleurs d'avoir si
longtemps entretenu les jeunes dans dans
l'illusion dans l'illusion que la
réussite de leur ambition est un droit
définitivement acquis monsieur quand je
dis si je serai sur le premier c'est une
vision de gc je le dis dans ce segment
elle
attend c'est évidemment courrier dans le
grand père grand père parler comme ça
des jeunes déjà peut-être enfin par une
culture ces criminels ces criminels
d'encourager les jeunes dans des
filières dont on sait parfaitement
qu'elle n'aboutisse pas y a pas de
débouchés à ses filières ces criminels
d'encourager les jeunes à acquérir des
diplômes quand même temps on est en
train d'année en année de dévaloriser ça
c'est vrai quoi qu'on est à la source du
problème ça y est la grèce bon ben vous
êtes d'accord
non car son discours
mais non on n'est pas d'accord
donnez-vous d'âge de tourner au moins
qu'on puisse avoir des passerelles je le
connais à ça
je le connais assez je connais assez à
la seule placé pour savoir que lui même
je donne est il du jour là il croque il
est dans le vrai il est victime du sud
du discours dans lequel il vit depuis 50
ans maintenant et dont il est complice
c'est ça le problème c'est à dire y
répète me rabâche imputable non il
rabâche éternellement son discours
populiste son discours conservateur et
son discours égalitaire et le rêve
égalitariste cimetière d'athènes vous
voyez quand même la preuve de ce que je
disais quand même pas parce que vous
avez quand même un discours qui sort
automatique vous appuyer sur un bouton
comme les communistes il ya 30 ans
peuvent et ça sort avec les murs et la
[__] j'en ai même mérité mais ils sont
en arrière je vais vous dire une chose
je penche personnellement évidemment
qu'il faut totalement sortir du statu
quo qu'il faut faire des réformes à
chaque fois qu'on a proposé des réformes
des vrais des vrais parce que tu si tu
dis on remet en cause le smic ce n'est
pas une réforme c'est un sacrifice n'est
pas une réforme mais quand à chaque fois
non tous les domaines la démocratie la
fiscalité le seul organisme urbaine à
chaque fois qu'on fait des proposer des
préformes les mêmes exactement les mêmes
qui ont le mot réforme à la bouche tout
le temps les refuse et qui leur faisait
des petits s'agit des refus n'est pas
cela qui tissent sans arrêt réforme
réforme répond ils ne sont pas les
nombreux bus tu fais tu t'emmerdes c'est
que des procès tu fais le projet aux
nantis tu fais le prochain à croix tu
fais le postulant aux amateurs mais
j'aime pas faire c'est au patron je dis
que j'ai qu'est ce qu'il faut ecoute-moi
deux secondes c'est vrai je dis que si
on veut dans ce pays en effet que les
gens acceptent y compris des sacrifices
quand ils sont les essais 1 il faut
qu'ils aient l'impression qu'ils sont
répartis justement répartis qu'on ne
demande pas toujours les sacrifices à
certains y compris des sacrifices qu'il
faut faire et que les autres non
seulement leur demande pas mais que
pendant ce temps là il ne cesse
d'augmenter leurs privilèges pas tu peux
pas être en désaccord avec ça même si tu
joues ton rôle voilà
jacques jambon c'est 3000 cette affaire
de messier que je vais pas interné parce
que le duo est tellement pas fait
maintenant jacques vergès et à la baisse
mois puisque c'est un homme de bon sens
sauf et il l'est souvent été dans la
nuit
charlotte vous en pensez quoi il faut
appeler le 110 que c'est hyper important
qui revêt la blu à vendre voilà
j'aimerais bien y aller dans pas trop
longtemps que j'ai pas pris mon
médicament l'asie alors à la base
bon alors c'est quoi la solution alors
philippe bas on va le savent pour la
france en laissant parler au delà du cpc
voilà quelques mois je répète ce que
j'ai dit d'entrée de jeu je crois que un
jour il faudra qu'un élément
catalyseur aux thèmes sans chimie 1
interviennent qui fait alors ça peut
être artificiel il peut être créée de
toutes pièces par un nouveau président
par une nouvelle majorité par un
gouvernement une vos valeurs de gauche
ou de droite peu importe ce n'est pas le
problème il faudra que toutes ces
structures vermoulu soit anéantie pour
que dans un consensus dans l'autre pas
dans une un consensus majoritaire si je
puis dire d une structure nouvelle se
substitue aux structures anciennes
notamment en matière d'emploi puisque
aujourd'hui c'est dans l'emploi ce qui
renvoie les ont remis aux problèmes
économiques générales je dis que ça
devra arriver ça arrivera nous sommes
dans une situation extrêmement
dramatique extrêmement je suis dit c'est
ça va péter jeu ça va péter je crois que
villepin a voulu être selon une
conception un peu bonapartiste
gouvernement des hommes ou
donquichottesque enfin tout ce qu'on
voudra ça relève de pathologies diverses
et des histoires d'hiver il a voulu
précipiter le mouvement disait vous
c'est toujours des procès à certains
égards cet égard on peut le comprendre
y'a même d'ailleurs les sondages le
disent c'est dit ça passe ou ça casse
rien de courage mais malheureusement il
n'est pas politique il a mal choisi son
moment il n'a pas d'assise populaire le
contexte et la veille a pas eu de
préparation il a même pas une véritable
assise parlementaire il est pas l'homme
de la situation et ses fichiers mal pris
alors concernant le 12 le dossier
lui-même alors on me dit qu est ce qui
surpasse à va déboucher je ne sais pas
les syndicats eux dont on comprend très
bien la tactique
son trait emmerder dans cette affaire
ils ne peuvent pas si des d'un autre
côté ils ont posé un préalable pensant
ça a été une épreuve de force on sent
que l'autre allait céder l'autre n'a pas
cédé ils sont très embêtés pourquoi ils
sont embêtés d'abord parce qu a pas
d'alternative il n'y a pas une
alternative politique
jouable c'est vrai on le sait je ne dis
pas de manière polémique mais la gauche
c'est en miettes et à tous tu rigoles
[Applaudissements]
al qadhi je rigole parce qu'être parent
et je crois que ça ensuite leur cohésion
elle et d'opportunités elle n'est pas
même pas structuré depuis très longtemps
leur art troisièmement et 6 cas plus
graves enfin s'il ya un troisième acteur
dans cette affaire est très inattendu
qui sont je le répète les lycéens les
collégiens les jeunes qui forment une
population
incontrôlable je dis pas qu'elle est
manipulée elle est un peu elle l'a été
en tout cas mais ils sont jeunes il ya
beaucoup d' irrationnelles mais quoi
alors il va lui acheter un discours
réactionnaire 120 lui-même atteint a
sûrement eu dans sa vie les problèmes
que ses enfants il sait bien ce que
c'est qu'une crise d'autorité sur la
jeunesse mais le discours est
actionnaire est à dix tours de bon sens
encore une fois les jeunes le discours
anarchistes et pseudo révolutionnaires
de jean-françois qualité vision
rétrograde monsieur maison tout à
l'heure je comprends pas tout à l'heure
ils étaient pour la réforme la
révolution il traitait tout le monde de
conservateurs de rétrograde tout à coup
il a complètement oublié qui disait ça
il ya 10 minutes et maintenant je suis
réactionnaire il est parfait mais au
final vous écris
mais comment vous travaillez en fait
sérieusement
est-ce que tu souhaites que ça peut être
que nous avec marseille que jose il faut
que ça fait oui quand je suis préparée
que je souhaite que je souhaite pas ça
mettra ça commence à péter et sa
dépendance à des porcs ça dépend pour
déboucher sur quoi ça dépend comment
vous sur le plan politique villepin
aurait pu tenir si sarkozy ne lui
retirait pas de systématiquement tu as
le tapis sous les pieds parce que tu as
oublié cet aspect avec une des raisons
pour laquelle il va sans doute échoué
c'est qu'il a une grande partie de sa
propre majorité et sarkozy qui veut
qu'il est chaud qui fait tout pour
qu'ils quand même bon il cela dit aragon
notre oreille entendre un journaliste a
vu cette ivresse a quand même c'est un
tout petit peu vrai mais c'est
fini c'est sarkozy menace mais sarkozy
avait été c'est réellement solidaire non
ce donneur mais non c'est un élément
c'est un élément un film ça c'est pas
vrai il n'a pas compté dans le rapport
de force il a d'ailleurs joué à peu près
le jeu le prof de problèmes nique sur le
poing levé ballard et le jeu de façon
formidable je reconnais non mais je
reconnais rennais d'une solidarité
splendide mais qu'est ce que tu veux je
reconnais vers bon mais je suis encore
une fois le problème n'est pas là il y a
deux dispositions dans le projet cpe qui
sont il est vrai
inacceptable dans des coins
elle c'est inacceptable qu'elle n'a pas
de place mais voilà c'est tout le
problème rappelons que vous trouvez à
l'état qui s'appelle tout et son
contraire
il et loire une loi la loi fillon voté
le 4 mai je crois qu'il guy oblige le
gouvernement qui qui qui rend le
gouvernement obligé plus exactement le
gouvernement oblige à consulter les
partenaires sociaux dès l'instant où il
s'attaque à une réforme dans dans le
social cette époque mais c'est quand
même incroyable de penser pour ça qu'on
peut penser à une provocation de la part
de villepin et pourquoi pas mais quel
choix intelligent qu'il convient de
villepin n'a pas observé cette loi qui
est une loi a minima que tu m'aimes une
loi que théorique quoi elle élimine
bonne conclusion c'est quoi cette finale
vient pas cette raison j'ai donc attaqué
parce que sa conclusion c'est pas la
question importante à laquelle je n'ai
pas de réponse bien évidemment et
personnes qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
jeudi que personne n'a intérêt à ce que
dans la situation actuelle à ce que ça
pète mis les syndicats ni le groupe
pourtant ça va péter vous mais non j'ai
dit ils sont quand même comme un thread
jeudi pour que ça pète et tu es enfin
thierry vous êtes d'accord je le sais il
faudra que ça mais la france ne peut pas
ne pourra pas continuer longtemps à
vivre sur le train sur lequel les
prendre il faut il faut en finir ce que
vous êtes un déclic c'est un
déclinologues est-ce que vous pensez que
le moment je suis pas du tout a décliné
l'offre chanteau la gc je traîne je suis
très pessimiste à court terme assez
pessimiste un corner mais je suis je ne
suis pas pessimiste à moyen et à long
terme la france a les ressources
nécessaires pour s'attirer je dis
simplement qu'il ya quelques réformes
mais de base de principes afer se
modifier les comportements du poste de
des français par rapport à l'argent par
rapport à l'égalité par rapport à
l'activité par rapport au travail
arrêtez de protéger les emplois mais
protéger les salariés alors que depuis
dacquois alors que depuis deux mois
depuis un demi-siècle en fait je t'adore
c'est parfait
je suis pas content je ne s'est pas
présentée ce soir mon programme des
animateurs les jeunes
conclusion jean françois
le vot questions sur le liquide moi je
suis très frappé personnellement d'une
qualité à la base mais vous n'imaginez
pas il ya aujourd'hui un peuple autour
de ddd 18 ans et même la manifestation
le prouve même ces manifestations le pot
il y a une énergie une créativité dans
la jeunesse une volonté de s'en sortir
d'imaginer des choses nouvelles de
secouer mais c'est je n'ai jamais vu ça
le moindre débat vous avez d un monde
fou qui disent que qui interroge qui
intervient qui pose des questions on
peut plus en faire on peut plus leur
raconter de blague je n'ai jamais mais
c'est vrai qu'au sommet alors c'est
terrible sénégal la couche du sommet
c'est épouvantable c'est pour ça que je
disais des élites ce que je fais
complètement changé ça c'est évident si
et quand il faut se mettre autour d'une
table et dire vous parlez privilèges
alors tous les privilèges sur la table
vous parlez sacrifices alors tous les
sacrifices nécessaires sur la table tout
le monde oui la nuit du 4 août c'est ça
oui c'est une solution prenons un simple
exemple finir est là
et quatre aux états généraux sinon la
nuit du 4 août c'est ça c'est puisqu'on
ne parle que de ça de privilèges et bien
les met sur la table sont logiques et
robert tu connais mais ça n'a jamais
avec la nuit du pin kung fu panda rien à
foot tu révises alors
c'est moi je moi seul exemple celle ci
par exemple ou décidé de réduire d'une
façon très importante les charges par
exemple 35 % de réduction des charges
ciblées sur les pme ou de l'artisanat
pour quatre salaires si vous en créez un
cinquième je prends simplement cet
exemple mais ça crée beaucoup plus
d'emplois que ça fait beaucoup plus de
bien beau père ait beaucoup de mesures
concrètes qu'on peut faire pour aller
dans ce sens d'où le nom du spectacle
tous les ans comme ça
c'est son rôle à lui c'est tout et son
contraire était qui a écrit son choc qui
a écrit que tout change parce que rien
n'échappe aux gens france la calabre à
jack ils sont bons mais ils les vendent
bien respectable
[Musique]
jacky rigaux
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir eric laurent journaliste
spécialiste des questions
internationales auteur d' enquête à
succès souvent le dossier secret shearer
ben 91 pour dénoncer les dessous de la
guerre du golfe la guerre des bouches
chez plon en 2003 les relations de la
famille bush avec l'entourage de ben
laden et saddam hussein le monde secret
de bouche chez plon en 2004 la religion
les affaires les réseaux occultes la
face cachée du 11-septembre réquisitoire
contre les ambiguïtés américaine et vous
publié aujourd'hui toujours chez plon un
livre qui s'appelle toujours la face
cachée mais cette fois la face cachée du
pétrole alors dans l'avant propos vous
dites l'univers du pétrole est
exactement de la même couleur que ce
liquide tant convoité noir je crois
qu'il faut d'abord expliquer que le
pétrole c'est la clé du monde
contemporain mais mais depuis toujours
c'est à dire que c'est pas seulement une
matière première qu'on extrait se dire
profondément parfois c'est aussi un
certain nombre de secrets de mensonges
et de manipulations qui sont
soigneusement cachée mais depuis des
décennies aux opinions et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est effectivement de
crocheter les portes et de découvrir la
vérité cachée derrière la réalité un
officiel alors vous commencez avec le
fameux choc pétrolier de 1973 et vous
affirmez et c'est un scoop il n'y a
jamais eu de véritable pénurie de
pétrole les pays producteurs n'ont
jamais imposé leur loi c'est un
gigantesque bluff en fait il s'était
secrètement entendu avec les compagnies
pétrolières pour faire quadruples et le
prix en 1960 ont créé l'opep dont les
pays producteurs créé l'opep
l'organisation des pays exportateurs de
pétrole entre 1960 et 1973 malgré leurs
efforts constants jamais les pays
producteurs ne réussiront à augmenter
même de quelques centimes le prix du
baril c'est impossible sable où il se
passe un événement considérable 1973 qui
passe totalement inaperçu et les ya là
un homme d'ailleurs kiki affi n'guessan
déclaration qui s'appelle david
rockefeller qui est à l'époque
probablement le personnage des plus
influents du monde des affaires c'est
l'héritier la dynastie rockefeller et il
est le président de chase manhattan bank
est donc aussi le plus gros actionnaire
de dixon la première compagnie mondiale
de pétrole
il dit en 73 ans je 1,73 à rome et
compagnies pétrolières vont avoir besoin
dans les prochains mois d'énormément
effectivement de 2,2 de cachou et
besoins financiers et chiffre même sa
3000 milliards de dollars pour une
raison très simple en réalité c'est qu'à
l'époque les grandes compagnies
pétrolières sont dans une situation très
très difficile mais qu'elle cache
soigneusement pourquoi parce qu'elles
ont des investissements énormes à
effectuer notamment en mer du nord et en
mer du nord où il est en effet donc
effectivement dès que de la construction
de la plate forme offshore très
compliqué et technologiquement très dur
et qui coûte une fortune c'est même
chose effectivement pour le pape laye en
alaska qui doit être construit qui va
coûter 10 milliards de dollars toutes
ces grandes compagnies sont prises à la
gorge est ce que j'ai découvert c'est
qu'elles ont encouragé les pays
producteurs à augmenter le prix du
pétrole est ce que vous dites eric donc
c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu en fait nous de
position unilatérale de la part des pays
producteurs c'est qu'ils se sont
entendus avec les compagnies pétrolières
pour augmenter les prix ce qui a fait
évidemment la fortune des compagnies
pétrolières qui a fait la fortune et
compagnie pétrolière risque également
l'infortuné pays producteurs mais une
forte tempête a fait factice dans la
mesure où ces pays producteurs de toute
façon effectivement n'avait pas les
moyens d'absorber ces surplus pétroliers
et c'était encore en fait un signe de
vulnérabilité supplémentaire parce que
ces pays producteurs ont été contraints
de placer justement leurs excédents
pétroliers dans les grandes banques
occidentales américaine danic et donc
elle était dans les situations de
dépendance accrue dans la mesure où les
faits ou du jour au lendemain les etats
unis la grande bretagne ou les pays
occidentaux aurait pu geler ses avoirs
donc ça n'a jamais été le cartel que
l'on raconte et cette puissance
pétrolière que l'on a décrit jamais
c'est un premier en fait c'était une
entente illicite quoi bon alors éric
leurent vous expliquer comment les usa
ont utilisé l'armé du pétrole saoudien
pour provoquer l'effondrement de l'urss
oui parce que nous sommes en 1981 et
arrive au pouvoir washington donc
l'administration reagan tout le monde se
rappelle les déclarations de reggane l'
axe du mal c'est vraiment l'objectif
essentiel c'est vraiment de mettre à bas
donc l'union soviétique et il ya une
surtout une découverte qui a été fait
par certains collaborateurs de reggane
notamment un que j'ai rencontrés plus en
plus avec roger robinson klein
économiste et il a découvert en
comptabilisant effectivement toutes les
rentrées en devises fortes de l'union
soviétique qui un empire il faut le
rappeler gigantesque à l'époque j'y vois
que tous les rentrées en devises sortir
les ventes d'armes les ventes d'or les
ventes de diamants et surtout les ventes
de pétrole
n'aboutissent qu'à des recettes de 24 à
26 milliards de dollars ce qui peut
paraître comme ans les normes et syriens
24-26 mire deux heures c'est même pas le
tiers du chiffre d'affaires d'une
entreprise comme exxon ou de la moitié
du chiffre d'affaires d'une entreprise
comme general motors est l'idée qui
germe effectivement notamment chez un
homme qui s'appelle qu'aisé à l'époque
qui le directeur de la cia c'est de dire
en effet voilà on va demander à l'arabie
saoudite d'inonder totalement je dire le
marché mondial en pétrole de façon à
faire chuter complètement les cours et
la halle à l'union soviétique
s'effondrera sera asphyxié
économiquement et ça va durer deux ans
et négociation de pression et c'est au
bout de deux ans les saoudiens saad et
du jour au lendemain enfin du jour au
lendemain en quelques mois les cours
évidemment chute et l'union soviétique
et gorbatchev reconnaît après d'ailleurs
est totalement asphyxiée et alors vous
expliquez que l'arabie saoudite
aujourd'hui et ça c'est vraiment le
grand scoop du bouquin voit ses
gisements arrivé à terme vous dites
c'est un secret mais c'est pas trente ou
quarante ans de réserve qu'il y a dans
le sous sol saoudien mais seulement 3 ou
s'est pas beaucoup non c'est très peu et
surtout mais c'est ce qui est une chose
assez fascinante c'est que tous les
chiffres par exemple concernant le
pétrole et les réserves prouvées ses
réserves prouvées ce sont les réserves
qui sont les réserves soit disant
officielle sur lesquels nous basons de
croissance et autres sources sont des
chiffres faux mais totalement faux pour
une raison très simple c'est que en 1986
par un simple jeu d'écriture c'est à
dire par une manipulation comptable les
pays de l'opep ont décidé d'augmenter de
65 % le montant de leurs réserves de
pétrole mais sans qu'il y ait une
nouvelle découverte par exemple l'arabie
saoudite la dernière découverte
pétrolière importante remonte à 1967
simplement c'était bon pour des raisons
aussi financière parce qu'il s'agisse
l'augmenter leurs quotas de production
de valoriser effectivement donc leur
production davantage et donc c'est ce
qu'on découvre c'est que marine l'arabie
saoudite qui a soi disant 260 milliards
de barils donc dans son sous sol et qui
n'en avait que 150 milliards dans cette
réputation comptable de 1986 médailles
dans une situation totalement mais
totalement artificielle vous avez sur le
grand champ par exemple les puits
pétroliers en arabie saoudite 90% des
prix pétroliers
sont représentés 90 % la production
saoudienne représentée par sept champs
pétroliers le plus grand d'entre eux
s'appelle gaouar et il fait 250 km de
long c'est le plus grand champ pétrolier
au monde il est dans les produits aux
failles des exploités depuis 1948 et
aujourd'hui les saoudiens pour arriver
encore à faire jaillir du pétrole de ce
champ effectivement sont obligés
d'injecter tous les jours c'est une
technique sont obligés d'injecter tous
les jours 7 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau pour maintenir une pression
suffisamment fort pour faire jaillir ce
pétrole auraient autrement il y en
aurait plus et la vérité c'est que quand
vous discutez avec les gens de l'aramco
l'aramco c'est le consortium pétrolier
qui avant d'être nationalisées était
dirigée par les américains comme
discothèques des pétroliers américains
ils vous disent il y a environ nous
avons toujours considéré qu'il y avait
130 à 140 ou 150 même milliards de
barils de pétrole saoudien et tout le
monde tombe d'accord aujourd'hui pour
reconnaître les chiffres officiels pour
dire il y à 100 milliards justement de
pétrole saoudien qui a déjà été extraits
alors sept locaux ont tiré cinq après 50
milliards de barils il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui 50 milliards de barils
c'est même pas deux années de production
de pétrole en arabie saoudite y en a ou
alors mais le vrai problème est là c'est
que nous sommes dans une situation
historique sans précédent depuis 1973
nous avons fort et partout tout le monde
tombe d'accord pour dire qu'aujourd'hui
on peut trouver encore du pétrole
on trouvera plus de grands gisements
géants sur lesquels nous avons tablé
effectivement notre croissance de
prospérer à fait d'accord jean françois
ouimet il centrale en particulier jean
revient justement d'asie centrale vous
prenez le cas de la mer caspienne ont
suscité par jean françois kahn
l'ouzbékistan d'ouzbékistan impasse
absolue on a cru que c'était
effectivement eldorado pétrolier le
kazakhstan à côté je veux dire on a fait
vingt entre 20 et 25 forages les trois
quarts sont avérés négatifs ya
simplement deux champs pétrolifères donc
vous dites que les réserves de pétrole
en fait sont beaucoup moins importante
que ce qu'on nous raconte en gros quoi
il ya un énorme bluff que
l'administration bush est parfaitement
au courant de cette situation et que
d'ailleurs dès son entrée en fonctions
bush avait prévu avait planifié
d'envahir l'irak il ya une carte qui
date de mars 2001 c'est à dire quelques
mois avant le 11 septembre que vous avez
vu ou envoie huit zones d'exploitation
de l'irak comme ça près de la frontière
saoudienne dire qu'ils ont pensé un
moment que l'irak a l'air en place et
l'arabie saoudite comme producteur de
pétrole oui parce que si une
administration en tout cas un pays au
courant de l'état réel des réserves
saoudiennes c'est bien évidemment les
états unis dans la mesure où les
compagnies américaines à exploiter
pendant des décennies le pétrole
saoudien et la chose très surprenante du
couvert c'est qu'en arrivant donc au
pouvoir et à la maison blanche en
janvier 2001 ce qui préoccupe
l'administration bush c'est pas la
sécurité c'est pas le terrorisme c'est
en effet l'énergie et de chaîner
d'ailleurs a tenu des propos quand il
était encore été d'halliburton un an
auparavant
très alarmiste dix ans dans quelques
années nous allons avoir besoin de 50
millions de barils jour supplémentaire
ou allons-nous les trouver et il ajoute
d'ailleurs effectivement de façon
confidentielle d'arabie saoudite ne
pourra pas les produire et que qu'est ce
qu'on découvre que en janvier 2001 il ya
création d'une commission sur l'énergie
qui est président et justement par le
vice président cheney et la chose très
surprenante c'est que cette commission
siège dans le plus grand secret on ne
connaît pas le nom des membres on ne
connaît pas l'ordre du jour on ne
connaît pas effectivement les personnes
objections qui sont qui siègent
effectivement ou qui sont effectivement
appelé dans cette commission au point
qu'une journaliste fort réputé est fort
estimé du washington post avec dana
milbank surnomme cette commission la
société secrète et je vous passe les
détails donc un certain nombre de
membres du congrès qui s'alarment se dit
écoute c est quand même cette commission
fonctionne avec de l'argent public par
conséquent effectivement les travaux de
cette commission doivent être rendus
publics refusent dans la maison blanche
qui oppose le privilège de l'exécutif
secret d'exécutive deux ans de bataille
juridique au bout de ces deux ans de
bataille juridique à la grande fureur de
chaîner trois documents sont son doigt
doivent être rendus publics par ces
commissions est l'un des documents que
vous disiez c'est une carte de l'irak
estampillée mars 2001 j'ai entre les
mains ou il ya en effet donc découpage
du tiers du territoire irakien en lui
l'eau dans les lacs à ses huit mois
avant le 11 septembre c'est lui oui
absolument une carte de l'irak avec des
zones des coupes et qui sont donc un
substitut à la production saoudienne oui
dans la mesure où on considère que
l'irak est le deuxième producteur
mondial et pourrait effectivement
supplée bien sûr je pense a pas marché
oui ça peut marcher ça c'est autre chose
n'a pas marché enfin de là à penser que
l'on septembre
été un prétexte pour s'emparer de cette
zone là ça a été en tout cas je suis de
cette tragédie a été une des procès
d'administration peut-être une divine
surprise oui bien sûr
alors au delà du déclin des ressources
d'arabie saoudite où les chiffres donc
des réserves pétrolières sont faux et le
vrai problème on le voit très bien c'est
que par exemple aujourd'hui pour 6 baril
tous les shows que nous consommons il ya
un seul barils seulement qui aient
découvert ça c'est tout à fait
intéressant ça c'est quand même très
très est par exemple les grandes
compagnies les dix premières compagnies
mondiales donc c'est quand même pas où
investir 11 milliards de dollars donc en
frais de recherche et d'investissement
et l on trouvait simplement l'équivalent
de 4 milliards de dollars de réserves
d'offres de ressources nouvelles c'est
peu il ça me rappelle une pub qu'est ce
que c'était pour un baril en vous un
donald pour les vannes
mais ce que vous dites là comme ça c'est
qu'en fait la cei et c'est la première
fois où il est à peu près officiel
qu'elle avait écrit il n'y aura plus de
pétrole mais c'est la première fois en
fait où on se trouve dans une situation
où le déclin mais vraiment marqué de la
production et des réserves coïncide avec
une espèce de mes deux formidable
explosion de la demande et la
consommation mariale avec la chine et
voilà mais quand vous allez en chine à
pékin j'ai rencontré le conseiller pour
le pôle énergie présence ou noir hélas
ce cet homme professeur maé qui est un
homme fort intelligent revenait de
washington il me dit où on la chose qui
nous préoccupe c'est pas tellement les
prix du pétrole et les parce que ça nous
sommes en mesure de payer beaucoup plus
cher le vrai problème pour nous ils
disent et la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement
nous avons été longue douze mille
kilomètres absolument et 10 les
américains sont en mesure de couper la
ligne d'approvisionnement quand ils le
veulent et on sent très bien que c'est
une énorme angoisse pour les chinois
c'est que les américains sont présents
en irak y sont présents au moyen-orient
et c'est donc en fait ils tiennent les
ressources pétrolières et les chinois
sont oui je demande bien sûr ils n'ont
pensé quoi philippe voilà y aura plus de
pétrole n'ont pas longtemps première
entre chose
ouais je ne sais pas quoi
vous intéressez pas encore de
substitution mais si justement je me
suis intéressé et le vrai problème c'est
qu'on ne trouve pas d'énergie de
substitution qui permettent le pétrole
en fait si c'était la matière première
et voilà c'est d'abord le pouvoir en
plus c'était évidemment elle offrait un
certain nombre de dérives et on est à
trois cent mille dérivés vous rendez
compte nos vêtements par exemple
l'alimentation
et des milliards de dollars consacrés à
la recherche du pétrole qu'elle est quel
est le chiffre clef l'équivalence en
substituant recherche de substituts de
pas beaucoup beaucoup moins mais il
affirme sans taj mais la vérité de
0,00 0 4% pour la storia du tout mais le
vrai problème c'est que pourquoi les
pétroliers ne font pas plus parce qu'ils
savent très bien qu'il n'ya pas de
d'énergie de substitution qui puisse se
substituer au pétrole ouais c'est ça le
vrai problème est le vrai problème au
fond les pétroliers et et quelque part
les produits producteurs en mentant sur
le montant des réserves sont tout à fait
dans leur rôle mais ce qui est tout à
fait de mon point de vue choquant c'est
justement quelque part le vire le
silence des états des états et des
gouvernements ici je trouve que c'est
impardonnable et quelque part
aujourd'hui on a on a un lobby pétrolier
qui aujourd'hui 2 oui mais c'est pas
seulement ça mais qui devient plus
alarmistes aujourd'hui que les
gouvernements par exemple vous avez vous
regardé le dernier rapport d'exxon exxon
commence à dire vous savez nous sommes à
une période de déclin rapide de la
production il faut se préparer à
l'après-pétrole ne sont pas de quelle
manière avec bon bref silence
assourdissant des gouvernements la
phrase d'henri queuille sur vos
américains y aurait cueille qui était
une grande figure de la quatrième
république disait il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de problème politique si complexe
soit-il qui ne puisse être réglée par
une absence de décision politique est
bien là je crois qu'il se trompe c'est
tout et le vrai problème est là
aujourd'hui c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
politiques sont complètement je dire
absents et hatton par exemple agence
internationale de l'énergie qui a
toujours été une agence qui réunit les
principaux pays industrialisés qui a
toujours été une agence extrêmement info
ricketts et présentant une vision est
vraiment une très optimiste 40 50 années
pétrole aujourd'hui tout est réalisé par
exemple le chef économiste fatih birol
je racontais il ya une anecdote l'année
dernière il ya un congrès sur l'énergie
ce type qui est qu un type brillant
prononce un discours très convenue et
puis descend de la tribune et puis se
met à parler avec quelques délégués en
disant de toute façon si l'arabie
saoudite n'est pas en mesure de produire
3 millions de barils supplémentaires
nous courons à la catastrophe savait
très difficile et à ce moment là une
liste de vie mystique est à côté qui lui
dit et vous pensez que heidi vous êtes
journaliste sait pas pour vous et la
journaliste bbc fait le tour des
délégués vous pensez que l'arabie
saoudite peut représenter effectivement
une alternative et les délégués
répondent 3 millions de barils jour
c'est impensable avarie bisso na bisso
dit ne peut même plus produire 300 mille
barils supplémentaires or voilà cet
homme fatih birol a une phrase
merveilleuse il a dit le pétrole c'est
qu'une petite amie vous savez un jour
qu'elle va vous quitter qu'elle va vous
briser le coeur d'eau qui au mieux vaut
mieux la quitter avant faut faire la
même chose avec le pétrole
des droits séville et j'ai plongé la
maison
oh
plus fort
j'accueille jean louis costes
[Musique]
jean louis costes bonsoir vous êtes né à
paris en 1954 parallèlement à des études
d'architecturé vous jouez dans des
groupes de rock vous voyagez en afrique
en amérique du sud en asie en 1986 la
musique devient notre activité
principale et vous cessez de jouer avec
des groupes pour créer seul des chansons
paroles très crues vous faites sur scène
des comédies musicales trash des opéras
porno des disques des films vous avez de
nombreux procès vous écrivez dans des
revues comme hermaphrodite cancer bordel
ça plaît
vous faites un texte plus long qui est
publiée qui s'appelle viva las merda
puis vous rencontré raphaël sorin chez
fayard vous publiez grand-père un
bouquin assez impressionnant par mois je
vous ai connu il ya dix ans à l'époque
de paris dernière
performeur underground super gore
officiers des horreurs sur scène mais
moi j'étais choquée et aujourd'hui je
vous retrouve en écrivant ces lignes à
bazzo ligne un bukowski ya est votre
livre est vraiment étonnant vraiment un
style quoi alors le pitch et la vie de
votre grand-père qui s'appelle garnick
sarkissian arménien plonger dans toutes
les barbaries du 20e siècle
quand on vous demande c'est une
autobiographie vous dit qu'effectivement
vous avez un grand père s'appelait garni
qu'était immigrés arméniens victimes de
pogroms et puis à 4 mots comme ça qui
sont kozak légionnaires bagnard et
collabos et ces quatre mots finalement
stimuler votre imagination et vous ont
amené à écrire ce livre désespéré épique
et décapant voilà
vous nous en dire un bout la
wii alors pour situer
en fait bon mon grand père après avoir
fait kozak légionnaires etc il a été
blessé à la guerre et ils ont lâché en
france et il n'avait pas de papiers pas
de travail savais que tu es c'est un
type qui avait fait que massacrer
travers toute la terre donc ça c'est
dans les années 30 ils rencontrent ma
grand mère dans le métro paris il a
séduit avec sa moustache à la
exotiques non et donc ma grand mère
tombe amoureuse et veut le présenter à
ses parents mais évidemment ça fait un
peu de bugs parce que ses parents sa
pavillon de banlieue et lui il arrive
arménien cosaques et donc c'est il
arrive dans le pavillon il sait pas
mettre les patins il n'arrête pas de
faire des gaffes sur gaffe
servez-vous le pool est prêt tout ça lui
joue la bouffe il prend le poulet
ils crachent les eaux dans le plat alors
voilà lecture commence et là je met les
lunettes du prophète assuré
donc il trace les autres plats comme ça
mais c'est dégoûtant la mer roquettes
dans sa serviette le père explose et met
une chose nous en amener beaucoup comme
ça des [__] moi pas debout ni au
noir mais n'y répond le fiancé bourré
c'est le face à face des mâles devant
les femelles le père descend son verre
de rouge le fiancé descend son verre de
rouge je ne jette en arrière à la rue ce
boom dans la vitrine aux bibelots la
sainte vierge de lourdes explose et fou
de la neige partout tout le monde est
couvert de flocons et d'éclats de verre
une seconde de calme avant l'orgasme
de lourdes que maman on m'avait offerte
mais si tu veux à toulouse i s big o
s'ennuie montjoie le père shop son fusil
entre la tête de cervelle saucisson la
vieille ce saut dans la cuisine pour
protéger le chat me nommer nous sauf toi
la fiancée retient le fiancé que veut
tout [__] watts en mode à gaoua goisil
quoi quoi mon chéri je t'en prie
calme-toi le père braque son fusil sur
les couilles de l'amant de sa fille non
papa n'ont pas les couilles le fiancé
shop le canon du fusil wa quoi toi moi
qu aux actes bousculade boum boum bam le
coup pas le calibre 12 pète mais les
plombs rate fiancée [__] ils
traversent la cage du canari déchiqueté
au point que cuit
ok bon c'est un cosaque quand même il
comprend qu'il a en face de nous un
calibre 12 alors ils se cassent le
fiancé bord traite par la fenêtre la
finance est amoureuse de lui pleurs du
sens mais elle aime tellement qu'elle
s'accroche à lui font ils piétinent les
rosiers fui vers la gare le père hurle
au milieu de ces néo tué avec son fusil
jallet team entend au rêve n'a jamais eu
d'influencé jolie heureuse pimpante
voulait présenter son prince charmant à
ses parents mais les parents sont cons
et le prince est lourd alors ça a mal
tourné évidemment d'étrangers la
séparait des vieux français pour
l'éternité
[Applaudissements]
quand je disais quand je disais c'est
l'hymne du club ce qui je crois que
j'étais pas loin voilà alors cette
écriture justement a duré six semaines
est enfermé dans une cave à saint denis
vous avez fait mille pages sans
orthographe sans ponctuation vous ai
donné tout ça à fayard ils ont remis ça
en ordre avec 38 de fièvre parce que
vous êtes atteints d'un paludisme qui
résiste aux aux médicaments 1 mais c'est
vrai que je tente en guyane ouais mais
souvent guyana ouais parce que bon comme
j'ai une vie dans une cave videmment
soit parce que c'est de la musique soit
la littérature j'ai besoin de m'isoler
comprend une cave et je fais des
concerts c'est encore dans des cadres
donc la tendance avait bien d'être en
guyane ou en grand air dans la jungle
loin d'internet loin de toi vous avez
une cabane en guyane au milieu de la
forêt
pas d'eau pas d'électricité par internet
d'une machette et des boîtes de sardines
et comme c'est arrivé là bas vous est
défriché votre votre terrain et j'ai
foutu le feu vous avez brûlé la moitié
de la guyane ça a duré deux mois je suis
arrivé en bon écolo les petits singes
petite tortue machin tout ça mais bon je
me fais mon terrain mais franchement
gentiment quoi là-bas les gens quand ils
foutent le feu ils foutent le feu
directs à la jungle un terrain du feu
est-ce que la jungle et humide ne peut
pas prendre feu bon évidemment j'arrive
en plein el nino ouais donc la guyane
est sèche ce qui arrive tous les mille
ans quoi ai-je poumon feu mais gentil
mon milieu de jardins à la française
avec précaution n'ont surtout pas abîmer
la forêt un petit feu au milieu de
terrain et la nuit j'entends du papa
papa tout le village était encerclé de
flammes et c'était moi l'étranger puis
ce squat et mon terrain parce qu'en
guyane on prend un terrain je n'avais
pas acheté le terrain et donc à vos
oreilles avec gros titres du journal le
coeur de la guyane entre eux en feu un
clandestin sur un abati clandestins
c'était moi quand même avant quand je
suis reparti mais tout penaud d'un petit
parce qu'il faut prendre un petit avion
josé même plus aller au village
généralement l'étranger que foutu la
merde quand je suis reparti je voyais
tout la forêt en flammes au loin un mois
et demi que sacrum
[Rires]
et alors quand j'ai connu vous étiez
vraiment donc comme je les dis vraiment
hardcore et puis là j'ai l'impression
quand même que vous découvrez une
certaine spiritualité vous dites qu'il
ya deux ans à dunkerque à la sortie d'un
à chaud vous êtes bourrés vous êtes la
poêle enfin c'est juste des chaussettes
en fait et là vous traîner dans la zone
industrielle près d'un centre leclerc et
vous tombez sur un calvaire avec un avec
un christ et là d'un seul coup vous
voilà il ya un retour à la spiritualité
qui s'opèrent non c'est à dire suis
sorti de la salle où je le fais un
spectacle en géant après spectacle au
space doit énormément mais un blizzard
effets de transparence entre l'alcool et
l'excitation spectacle je suis
complètement barré donc j'étais même à
poil il fait super froid il gelait tout
était glacée et je vois bon c'est que
des supermarchés les zones industrielles
le l'aca était un scot au milieu d'un
échangeur salle et détruit quoi et jouer
cette croix qui se dresse dans une sorte
de petite jungle jeu là bas monde comme
ça quand on est bon on fait tous passent
la grille en fer forgé tout un truc
moyenâgeux quoi je vois une source
bon je savais que quand il ya une source
j'ai capté que c'est une source magique
ou un truc j'ai pissé dedans d'en faire
une offrande j'ai regardé ce christ et
d'un coup franchement je tombé à genoux
mais un truc de malade alors j'ai pas du
tout pratique sérieuse j'ai capté trop
mais c'est au niveau de la pitié si il
fait super froid tout le monde s'amuse
là dans cette salle à se défoncer tout
ça ce mec à poil trop sifflé personnes
en a rien à [__] ça m'a vachement
touchés ben j'ai compris que c'est une
religion même le plus puissant des
papous des rois il a une victime sur son
victimes voilà alors que toutes les
religions présentes des gens glorieux
bouddha en or bien gras là où le christ
ressuscité comme en orient et là on
europe les mecs ils mettent le mec dans
la merde sam a super touché parce que
moi je suis quand même un clochard quasi
j'ai vu un mec dans la merde et je
recommence depuis ce jour là je
m'intéresse vachement au rituel
catholique c'est peut-être mon côté show
théâtral tout ça je m'intéresse beaucoup
catholicisme du point de vue du rituel
vous avez raison
jean louis gosse
m
je suis pas les armes
[Musique]
alors vous n'avez pas pu écrire jean
louis costes vous dites je m'enfonce ray
toujours plus en moi même sans répit
jusqu'à ce que je trouve la sortie est
vraiment parti dans le truc quoi ouais
je pense que j'aime ont fermé dans ma
cave il ya un duel qui va s'ouvrir
l'infini je vais voir qui est un autre
monde inter de ma tête qui est plus
grand que l'amazone ouais alors à faire
une interview à prendre ou à laisser
alors je vais dire des adjectifs vous
allez me dire si c'est à prendre ou à
laisser en ce qui vous concerne d'accord
misogyne ouais ouais j'ai peur du vagin
mais j'aime la femme néo réac
ah ouais je suis totalement
réactionnaire ça c'est clair chez toi
l'envers ni viste
oui quand je bande pas
raciste non pas du tout alors
dégueulasse
enfin on dit que je fais des trucs
dégueulasses mme pour moi c'est juste la
normale on est plein de merdes sont
obsédés sexuels
façon 1 % du temps quoi quand je pense
provocateur
bon franchement je me rends pas compte
c'est vrai que se mette une carotte dans
le cul pour certains c'est une
provocation mais pour moi c'est juste un
gag ça peut être un rangement
et la prochaine fois
la prochaine fois je n'ai une boîte de
petits pois gore
non romantique génial ah oui sûrement
produit marketing très étudié il faut
demander à son
antihéros mais à force d'être anti héros
c'est comme le christ on atteint la
gloire ni aux beaufs
en fait quand j'ai raconté l'histoire
mon grand père j'ai vu que derrière les
beaufs des années 50 coucher devant leur
télé il ya eu des super héros entre 1900
opportuniste
ouais parce que j'ai compris que mon cas
rouge pour en faire un business
politiquement incorrect moi je sais pas
ce que ça veut dire je suis politisé
comme mon chat c'est à dire que le sait
peu je m'en fous mais si la bagnole cram
je m'en fous pas parce que je me cachais
dessous pour me protéger des chiens
dangereux
moi qu'une bombe comme artiste de merde
ouais mais bon
maire d'artistes aussi on pourrait dire
où n'importe quoi artiste de merde
névrosé j'étais des brosses de mes
larmes sauver cynique
non je suis pas cynique passionnés
fachos
fachos c'est une autre époque jeu s'en
ressent vraiment pas cette problématique
de la refuse intégral antisociales
oui carrément
gros cons
ouais j'suis con mais j'ai remarqué que
plus on va vers un sujet qu'on comme les
obscurs où le cac a plus on découvre des
trucs géniaux quand tout me mépriser ça
faut le reconnaître mais moi même je
trouvais que c'était con mais
l'intelligence et dans l'économie
showman way a forcé une question
d'expérience un poster
ça vous de juger
alcoolique non pas du tout d'ailleurs un
demi verre de champagne du film bourré
paranoïaque
totalement je veux le danger partout
j'étais sûr que vous alliez annulé
l'émission
homosexuel refoulé ah oui d'accord la
preuve la carotte
est peut-être ap
[Rires]
du cacao
infréquentable il ya des filles qui
tombe amoureuse de moi quand la
végétarienne
sympa
sympa ben ouais pour mon chat ouais
petite [__] extensible
jean louis costes grand-père séduit
messieurs brian artésien
[Musique]
bien eric et jacques je vais vous
laisser filer merci d'avoir avec lui
merci
ok
j'accueille guillaume blanc
[Musique]
bonsoir guillaume disons le tout de
suite j'ai que le mari de sandrine
bonnaire à bâle 11 y est voilà bravo on
l'a reçue la semaine dernière et vous
venez à tour de rôle parce que vous
n'avez pas de baby sitter elle allait
commencer l'émission et je le finis ce
soir on fait une sorte de parenthèse la
semaine exactement quand vous regardez
les enfants je pense vous êtes des
visiteurs
on a tout à fait confiance
alors vous êtes également scénariste le
fabuleux destin d'amélie poulain 30
millions d'entrées dans le monde 8 en
france un long dimanche de fiançailles
toujours avec jeunes et les travailler
qu alain chabat pour le marsupilami avec
barbet schroeder pour mesrine pour
langmann même si c'est pas votre
scénario qui a été retenue in fine et
alors tous les cas vous êtes un des plus
grands scénaristes français aujourd'hui
ce qui est très marrant c'est évidemment
on en arriver là vous avez été serveur
coursier chauffeur-livreur ce
encourageant pour les jeunes ce caporal
dans l'infanterie de marine
déjà vous vous tenez votre journal à
l'époque dans l'armée après armé vous
avez été acheteur d'emplacements
publicitaires et quand même j'ai fait
une école de théâtre et vous acheter un
bouquin qui s'appelle comment écrire un
scénario de michel chion absolument pas
là et j'ai écrit dans ma chambre de
bonne un scénario mais d'une manière
vraiment je m'étais calé sur le livre
mais c'était vraiment très intuitif
ouais et quand j'ai terminé ce scénario
qui ressemblait pas grand chose qui
était disons deux moyens métrages on
peut dire je vais pas très bien mesurer
le times et lumière et je savais pas du
tout comment faire parce que je
connaissais personne et je les envoyais
part par la poste jean pierre jeunet
après avoir vu de l'iccat est saine et
en cherchant le nom dans l'annuaire en
bas de chez moi que je vraiment je sais
pas à qui m'adresser mais il m'a répondu
et
savez il m'a fait travailler sur la cité
des enfants perdus
il m'a présenté diane bertrand avec qui
j'ai écrit un samedi sur la terre qui
était mon premier scénario est
finalement mon deuxième scénario porte à
l'écran c'était amélie poulain donc ce
qui s'appelle quand même
voilà
j'adore j'adore son histoire
alors après amélie faisait déjà publié
un roman qui s'appelait les années porte
fenêtre au seuil est aujourd'hui publié
le deuxième s'appelle happy hands avec
un achat n d malheureusement pas happy
end alors le pitch c'est quoi j'ai un
peu là marcel aymé pour moi oui ça on
disons un conte oriental à la française
il ya c'est l'histoire de deux destins
qui sont liées au départ que le sort ses
parts et dont on suit le parcours
parallèle jusqu'à ce qu'ils se recoupent
voilà ça c'est le petit pitch le
pitchoun mais c'est celle ci je précise
donc c'est celui de naoufel d'un côté et
qui est sûr qu'ils le sort a tendance à
saché en est un petit garçon d'origine
marocaine qui a jamais eu de chance quoi
ouais c'est vrai et l'autre c'est celui
de sa main droite qui est un vrai
personnage dans l'histoire et qu' un
moment effectivement se retrouve amputée
on ne peut pas lui greffer elle s'évade
du labo on s'apprête à la la disséquer
elle essaie de le rejoindre on suit en
parallèle toutes les étapes de son
aventure pour rejoindre naoufel et
l'histoire de naoufel en parallèle voilà
à partir d'un moment donc la main
intervient comme un protagoniste à part
entière du roman et devient même l'amant
d'une jeune fille à un moment cette
marque absolument elle a toutes sortes
d'aventurés elle rencontre un labrador
chien d'aveuglé
elle se retrouve dans un jardin public
dans une église et un moment
effectivement il ya un passage assez
érotique matri 0,1 seulement et parce
que cette fille dans son lit elle à
cette main tu vois qui
es tu me regardes série je te regarde
que c'était la seule fille bah oui voila
je te regarde on a bouffé le 10 nov
l'afld il a inscrit magique aux siens
oui alors ça c'est quelque chose qui
existe c'est d'ailleurs barbet schroeder
qui m'a raconté sa qui existent en
colombie nous on n'a pas encore ça ça va
arriver et qui est l'équivalent de la
drogue des violeurs qu'on met dans un
verre dans les boîtes de nuit et là bas
ils ont fabriqué en aérosol c'est à dire
qu'il suffit de demander un
renseignement à quelqu'un dans la rue il
se penche en effet et après on
a fait ce qu'on veut voilà c'est à dire
retirer le contenu de son compte en
banque dans un distributeur ou c'est
eric d'accord en colombie c'est plutôt
ça qui les intéresse c'est
ici c'est autre chose mais c'est un truc
qui existent alors ça existe ça va
arriver ça va
évidemment les questions
johan petro
plutôt bientôt à la fin de
votre bouquin sandrine bonnaire oui oui
beaucoup et le premier aussi d'ailleurs
le premier il ya une petite anecdote
c'est que amélie poulain quand même pas
mal changé ma vie comme on le disait est
un des premiers prix d'amélie était le
prix du film romantique de l'année et et
sandrine était actrice romantique de
l'année au festival de cabourg et on
s'est rencontrés à ce festival où c'est
quand même vrai
belle histoire ils sont rencontrés au
festival du film romantique ou chez soi
au festival des films pornos
vous écrivez un scénario pour elle en ce
moment on écrit ensemble même on écrit
ensemble effectivement c'est
c'est valable pour le moment c'est pas
on a écrit 50 pages mais on on va
c'est un film qu'on va faire ensemble
mais elle vous adore
soit beaucoup moins ici c'est réciproque
alors parvenir sans cesse sur votre
femme évidemment mais on va faire comme
une interview et je sens la part de
table
alors qu'il y aura par votre femme de
quoi vous parle sont le plus souvent ben
d'amélie poulain d'amélie poulain à part
votre femme qu'elle est la plus belle
femme du monde
ah
c'est tous les personnages qu'elle
interprète je suis mais vraiment
amoureux d'elle
à part deux femmes qui vous a fait le
plus beau cadeau de votre vie
alors je dirais quand même jean pierre
jeunet en ouvrant sa boîte à lettres
est-ce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
qu'il faut pas leur aux boîtes à lettres
il l'aurait pas ouvert je serai pas là
ce soir à part votre femme qui vous a
excité récemment
personne
à part votre femme qui vous prend la
tête parfois ah bah moi même alors s
abandonne femme qu'avez vous fait de
mieux dans la vie
écrire je crois que c'est vraiment la
chance de ma vie que ça me soit tombé
dessus un peu accidentellement c'est
vraiment la chance de ma vie
à part votre femme de qui écoute et vous
les jugements sur votre travail
de tout le monde
à part votre femme qu'est ce que vous ne
voudriez surtout pas me prêter nîmes a
fini ma belle fille n'y
met de l'argent par exemple sans
problème à part votre femme qui coûte
plus cher dans la vie
ma fille
à propos de sam de quoi pourrait-on
parler ce soir
2-2 de tout et même d'elle mais vous
savez ici c'est pas le genre de la
maison est riche c'est bien
ça s'appelle la brillante et
monsieur
passons blind test
bon jouer avec nous la bande de radio
plus
[Musique]
pasqua
bonsoir y est qui et sébastien c'est moi
mais julien c'est moi qui ai thomas
raison monsieur qu'est pierre témoin a
délaissé le samedi à 12h10 en clair sur
canal et ses produits par yves le
rolland le directeur artistique des
guignols voie sacrée drôle supporter du
fc nantes un déconneur vous n'êtes pas
tous les manques qui
la fin un ballet depuis qu'eric patrick
bosso elle a craqué non c'est ça alors
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble alors
vous avez vous tourné pour le monde
connaît toute façon vous regardez la
portable tous les cas de la tension
c'est compliqué tout ça vous avez dire
milito serge attention 1 2 3 magnéto
serge et à demain
si on inclut 7
domi a famille yach pas manger une
délation négation
de la baie ou bien de l'herbe jeta
ramène de ouarzazate ont l'astuce est
super jamais le cheat dommages à cholet
s'est envolé mais il faut brûler les
pilotes s'est pas écoulé
l'unité de la gauche dominique 7g
ségolène revienne tout récent passé
c'est vrai pour tout le monde
dans la guerre la famine guest même si
t'as pas de pognon c'est sarah thomas
grognon aux nonnains
présente représente on est
toi même tu sais guère environs de lune
c'était trop risqué
camille dumas alice lefranc changera de
charge nouri clément
kantisme ouvriers
rien
à
l'extérieur on embarque tout ce qui est
en cause c'est les meilleurs soldes les
soldes coeur on nous empêchera pas
d'acheter mon père noël du monde avait
peur
[Musique]
on perd sur canal les messieurs on est
heureux ce soir on était asocial
et pour mettre les dix j'appelle rend la
blanc
en meublant chroniqueuse musique sur
pink tv 1 et donc pas en générique de
fin on entendra sos rescue me par
rihanna voilà c'est mon nouveau morceau
préféré là que vous avez choisi ma
chérie connaissez le principe très bien
alors vous êtes près des enfants on
commence donc c'est l'équipe d'astrid
veillon contre l'équipe de philippe
tesson attendant a gagné ce bar est déjà
allé courage
aujourd'hui très bon niveau
[Musique]
m
on continue donc un poids bon l'équipe
de philippe tesson bravo
c'est vanessa rousso
est ce qu'il est
j'avais à l'époque où il était devenu sa
part à dijon c'est lui non
[Musique]
magie avec toi moi de ne rien [__]
connais pas galérer
ses chansons le chanteur
oh
mais bien ce morceau
[Musique]
on savait deux points pour le titre de
finir à 10 ans bondit même pas pour lui
de finir en vue
on continue photo aline ambiance
olivier minne
packagées
[Musique]
m
hélas donc ça fait 3 points pour
l'équipe de philippe tesson continuant à
s'inquiéter elle est récente wedding
c'est bien qu'oui
[Musique]
on continue
tajan thouet
elles sont appliquées
je
bravo tom jones effectivement continue
aurore
[Musique]
directement dacquois quoi un moment bien
dans ma droite
pour la mairie
cinq points pour l'équipe de philippe
tesson un point pour tes adversaires
philip wee jean-françois tête je suis
venu sur l'arménie est la pire
continues sic
[Musique]
celle ci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avi
six points pour l'équipe tout aussi
aucun trion
scusez à cette énorme mais on continue
en faisant tout sapiteur
attention
nous disons non
en tout cas
attendez oui plus élevé
m
oui
[Musique]
attention
serge bref je pense qu'ils seront là
qu'une fois ouais
c'est pas sûr tu crois lab c'est drôle
ce qu'il faut réserver ouais ouais
alors laurent foot
amin
l'effort
oui
du riant ouais
john john effectivement il est marrant
laurent parce que il fonctionne vraiment
arabe et après tu rames du ram et toc
navette actions ou mac c'est la même
comprendre comment ils fonctionnent en
brouille
après tout les cas l'équipe de philippe
tesson est à 8 c'est tout ce que j'ai
l'habitude le reste
mais j étais content
[Applaudissements]
attendez vous savez que c'est à
soufflage ya paire d'as
j'ai entendu du soufflage et l'hyper
d'âge pour cette fois d'accord pour
cette fois je les trouvais quand même
j'ai dit à tous qui a soufflé hadji à
perdre à jonathan sion n'y a pas de
discussion là-dessus aurora toi
oui
sauvé
c'est à leur tour
et voilà ce que riber est effectivement
bravo extrait de run the world in day de
primes bravo bravo sont déjà sauvé
l'honneur mais quand même l'équipe de
tesson à 8 et vous avez trois astrid
commentaire
au hasard avant que tu démarres ouais
donc se lancer la fin du par équipes
c'est le libéralisme chère à philippe
tesson chacun pour sa gueule on écrase
les faibles
allaient en une phrase écrase le fais
bien attention c'est le banco en or
[Musique]
sébastien parent qui l'écoutent me
coller des baffes alors ça c'est là mais
ça veut dire que on va voir dans la
série des banques oh là là là tu es déjà
très bien baronne sébastien c'est clair
on rangera toi
oui
la lumière
comme mon ami
pourquoi
tout le monde sait bien
[Musique]
ixina chronos bordeaux
à
sébastien un point c'est pas notre point
on continue le méga banco
bosseur
[Musique]
à bord
whitney houston bravo
je
mais c'est juste du sien pour le moment
c'est sébastien donc j'ai des musiques
d'été rôle assez chiant quand est ce que
tu dis rien ne
sert même si une fille qu'il a choisi le
lieu juliette on continue or
[Musique]
loi
là
c'est donc sébastien qui est le grand
vainqueur de la soirée
bravo
reclus à travers toi c'est toi nos coûts
jean-françois je te félicite pas coûter
quitterait la salle ouais
bravo tu as été excellent enfin oui à la
fin mais c'est le moment où il faudra
être excellent cibona rendre sa ligne
donc le pétrole gorge de monde que la
justice est pourrie ouais et que le sida
fait des millions de morts voilà et
c'est la fête
mais c'était tout le monde en parle en
tous les cas avec des
batteries
[Musique]
près du lycée docteur hull en tournée
dans toute la france albert dupontel
ont fermé deux heures
gentil le 5 1 charlotte valandrey la
mode en ce sens mais que cherche midi
le sidaction jusqu'au 2 avril ont fait
le 110 monde
est-ce à leurs pauvres c'est publié chez
plon htv ont dû mener leur tâche avec
sara giraudeau isabelle aubret au petit
théâtre de paris avance et 4 avril
jean-françois qualité sont merci
ces dames
laurent la face cachée du pétrole c'est
chez blue jean louis costes on perd
c'est chez fayard pinot blanc amis
averti c'est au sun la hauteur ces deux
châteaux et julien cazarre
c'est rapide radio plus tous les samedis
à vue
non chroniqueuse musique dans l'émission
le set sur pink tv tous les jeudis à 19h
garde ce à quoi s'étaient tous prendront
part au rendez vous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
et je
m
[Musique]
answers gamme écoles
esprit
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est tentant
m
il
[Musique]
m il
mais
[Musique]
pas de sel
hatoyama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le leader
des tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible